Hello,
you dirty freak pitches.
Welcome to the new world.
Welcome to the future.
Welcome to the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
This episode is brought to you by stamps.com if you go to stamps.com and wow,
how long it takes one to delay the guys that live in the past time.
Here's to living in the past.
People listen to your shit already happened.
Um,
if you go,
what stamps.com is,
um,
a service that allows you to measure stuff at home with your own scale and
then
shit through the Internet.
Man,
you guys are high route.
You measure things.
You mentioned the weight.
Is that rude to say?
Measure the weight.
That's what it is.
You measure the weight yet.
Fucks.
How,
first of all,
how dare you,
all of you.
I was thinking I don't like it.
You ready sir?
Um,
for some reason when I'm typing in Jre it's not sending me to that.
How are you getting there?
What do you type it in?
Like as far as you type jre right?
stamps.com stamps.com forward slash Cho,
right?
No,
no,
no.
That's not it.
No.
How did you get it?
stamps.com you enter in the code word Jre,
right?
If you buy any of the kitty cat tee shirts at Brian red band cells,
that's how he makes them.
He sends him rather through stamps.com if you like a have a small business and
you're trying to go to the post office and wait in line and get your shit,
wade and different labels on boxes,
you're going to go crazy.
It's not,
it's not healthy this way.
You do it all on your home computer,
super sample.
They could do it for your weight.
We want to scale.
They give you a scale.
They uh,
they give you,
it's a $110 value.
If you enter in the code word jre and uh,
it's,
there's a nose,
no risk twat say it again.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer,
including the digital scale and up to $55 of free postage.
So they give you a sweet deal and if you like,
if you're selling shit,
it's,
it's a really easy way to deal with things as opposed to like hiring someone to
handle it.
You can actually handle it yourself and if you're not selling shit,
what do you want to work for somebody forever.
It's just go make some macrame and salad.
No,
no person is online.
It's the future cancer from licking stamps.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You want a wet a sponge at Fox.
Don't people that can shit.
You remember when you have to lick stamps?
Sleep bitches.
Yeah,
I remember that.
That's a bad time man.
From [inaudible] dot com mouth are sticking together.
Hey,
Ari
were also brought to you by hover.
Hover is a internet domain name company that is owned by the people that own,
is it hover.com forward slash Joe Rogan?
Is that what it is?
[inaudible] dot com forward slash Rogen hub or
fooling slash let's Jesse,
you got to get all these people to make the same one.
All make the same one together.
They can coach them no time because they don't want to pretend that each other
exists.
They're like,
if you're a single guy,
you've got a bunch of girlfriends.
So they don't want to know that they have his other girlfriends.
Nobody wants to think that.
Why should we change our shit to GRE?
You know,
just because squarespace.com uses that.
I mean,
what the fuck man hover is,
uh,
the domain company that I use actually.
And if you,
um,
if you're like a techno idiot,
like myself,
I do not know how to do anything correctly other than really easy,
simple,
intuitive shit like Facebook or Twitter or something like that.
But I don't,
I don't know how to,
you know,
if I can register a website like super easy and it has things that you normally
have to pay for,
like who is domain name privacy,
which is a,
that's,
that's key.
If you order Ari Shaffir his legs and then,
you know,
you put that shit online,
you don't want people to know he's just steady beaten off to Arusha,
his legs,
family,
people.
I mean they're sexy or it could be dig party in my mouth.com which we own.
Good.
How are you going to dig party in your mouth.com because we were just trying to
make the point we want wanted to make the point.
You could hide this because it would be embarrassing if people knew that you had
Dick Party in your mouth.com [inaudible] dot com forward slash Rogan is the
sweet spot.
If you go there,
you will save 10% off your domain name registrations.
And uh,
but like I said,
it's the same company that owns Ting,
very ethical company,
very reasonable rates and I use them too.
So go,
they support the podcast and we support them and blah,
blah,
blah.
Anyway,
on a.com last sponsor,
o n n I t,
use a code name,
Rogan and save 10% off any supplements.
That's it.
Fuck it.
Let's just not say anything more.
I talked too much.
Boom.
We got Jason Silva.
Boom,
we got all we shift fee.
Boom.
We got Dunkin Trust.
So this is the Uber podcasts,
it lunches.
Now
the Joe Rogan experience.
Hey,
Joe Rogan podcast.
Praise Odin,
Duncan Trussell praise owed and Jason Silva.
Praise Odin.
Praise Odin,
ours.
Your fear.
We were finally,
we're finally together again.
This is a fucking super podcast.
This is really great.
This is the sexy as it gets for me.
I'm very happy to be here,
man.
Thank you for having me back.
It was so cool.
Running into you with the global future 2045 conference,
man,
that was bad ass dude.
That was awesome.
That is your world,
dude.
That's where I was actually talking about with Duncan about this a little while
ago.
What was your impression?
Because I
mean that's kind of like the Mecca of the singularity.
You guys visited Mecca,
singularity
and because we visited for the show,
we got to talk to some really cool people that probably would never sit down and
talk to us.
You know like Aubrey de grey.
I got to talk to RBT.
Greg.
We'll have that on the show.
And you know,
you guys got to talk to,
what was the gentleman's name of the robot?
Uh,
Hiroshi.
Hiroshi Ishiguro.
Hiroshi Ishiguro crazy robot.
Man Really had limbs?
No,
the one,
that little baby one somewhat limbs creeps me out because that one responds to
you in conversation.
It understands what you say in response to you.
So you're like,
hey,
how you doing?
And it goes,
good,
how are you?
And then it's like,
and it's like,
good man,
where are you from?
He's like,
I'm from Tokyo.
And I'm like,
oh cool.
Did you like to travel here?
He's like,
yeah,
it was fun.
But here's the thing,
it's this like humanoid baby with no limbs,
which feels like the beginning of like a creepy Scifi movie.
It starts out with showing like the first AI,
but it's limitless.
So it's this like weird thing like,
so we're going to build them,
but they're going to be like a little circus freaks without limbs felt really
honking.
Be weirder if it was limbless or if it had limbs,
it couldn't move.
Paralyze you with his nubs.
You're right.
But that's why I was freaking customer responds to you like a human and it's
cute.
You immediately anthropomorphize it and you start to respond to it like it's
alive.
And at some point it'll be so good at responding that by all measures that we
know about when it comes to knowing your,
for your son you have a subjective experience or if you have a subjective will
just believe that they're conscious at that point.
Are they just going to be these living thinking things that we keep like
limbless behind like uh,
you know behind a rope so people can like throw money and look at it.
I mean it was just freaked me out the presentation of it.
I didn't think he was,
I don't think they're going to,
I think one thing that people haven't thought of with robots yet is that they
think that they're going to be confined to one form.
I think the reality is going to be that they are going to be able to disassemble
and did individual droplets if they want to.
They're going to be these self assembling things that can kind of determine
what it's going to be.
It's going to be,
but think about that in a way.
It's kind of like time lapsing reality because what are atoms if not self
assembling linkup with other atoms and become cells and then those cells like
self assembled into into tissues and organism mean the whole story of the
universe.
The whole,
the opposite of entropy is extra p right?
The things that move towards greater complexity and self assemble.
So we will talk about robots or nanotechnology.
It's just,
it's like an acceleration of it so that it becomes discernible to us from this
scale.
And this is funny because it already exists.
When Mckenna talks about his DMT experience,
he calls himself transforming machine off.
So it's almost as though he's come in contact with a future version of what
these a androids are going to do.
Stop.
If you think if you accelerated life,
I mean time is all,
it's all our perspective.
If you accelerated our life,
human life,
the experience of humanity.
Yeah,
but accelerated at times a billion,
right?
And you got to see the first single cell become multicellular and on and on and
on.
Cities rise,
people fly.
And then the earth crash again.
You got,
you would get to see it all in like some sort of a psychedelic trip.
It only takes three minutes and you would see the the earth form out of the
cosmos.
I mean you could,
that's that psychedelic,
I mean that might as well be a mushroom trip.
100%
I mean if you could like literally just a perspective thing.
It's a time thing.
All a perspective.
Like even when you see time lapse of trees growing,
do you see the tree and aims towards the sun plants like came towards us.
I mean it's kind of crazy.
It's almost like agency itself,
which is that what they called it?
You know the life force that there's agency plants seem to have it through time
lapse.
Like you see agency intent like if wants to go towards Kevin Kelly.
Okay.
They're the trippy white co founder of wired in his book what technology wants.
He calls technology that technium he says it's the seventh kingdom of life and
then it also has wants and needs and he says that if we were able to zoom out
and remove ourselves from the being the co participants in creating technology,
it would actually look like the technology itself is self assembling and has a
direction like the time lapsing of plants,
which is crazy.
And then when Mckenna was tripping out and he starts talking about singularities
hello,
hear the echo with Kurzweil and Mckenna tennis tripping on DMT and talking about
singularities,
he's talking about universes that engender novelty universes that allow the
sprouting of new possibility.
It's the same thing that Kevin Kelly's writing about and its technology book to
see like the respected technologists writing these books about what's happening.
You know,
even Eric Schmidt,
the age of augmented humanity and Google.
Google represents the literalization of the psychedelic dream.
You know the literalization of the idea that we are expanding our minds with
these technologies,
whether they be chemical technologies or whether they be these external
technologies.
What you're saying.
This is why it's hilarious when you hear people start railing against,
it's unnatural.
We shouldn't do it.
Because what you're saying is like,
no,
actually there appears to be some form of transcendent invisible architecture
that all things grow upon in a similar way.
100% technology,
humans.
It just stretches on this invisible framework and reveals a whole bunch of
hidden and underneath all things,
which seems to be this ever perfecting.
Absolutely ever complexifying harmonious expression.
That's right.
And peer dish,
our Dean,
who was a famous Jesuit called it the Omega point,
he called it the Omega Point.
He got pushed out of the church because he basically sort of divinize the idea
of the singularity and he was using the language of God,
but he was talking about this move towards complexity and the phenomenon of men.
And man was the point in which evolution became self aware and started directing
its own evolution.
Doesn't that echo whether we were talking about it in the futures conference?
So you see these echos,
you see these patterns that connect,
you know the whole idea of cyber delex,
right.
Look,
so cybernetics and computers and then psychedelics and you know,
chemical technologies and they collide and what's
known as Cyber Delek.
That all started in the sixties and seventies in Silicon Valley when the
computer scientist or tripping on LSD and working on creative problems.
Yeah,
Xerox Parc augmenting human intelligence.
There's a book by John Markoff called what the dormouse says,
which talks about that,
where that came from.
I mean you have to think that these people were out of their minds when they
were conceiving of a world in which these computers could be wirelessly sending
our thoughts across time and space at the speed of light and that we're all
going to be connected and see our faces on these like machines like,
I mean you have to be,
you know,
way psychologically or metaphorically tripping to even think so far outside the
box.
So it's not like Davinci was so fascinating and look a lot of stuff that he came
up with,
it really didn't come to fruition in that form,
but you could see that he was like thinking of these concepts like way ahead of
everybody else who's saying he was just really like,
what a fascinating,
fascinating guy.
That must've been all completed.
I'm envisioning the future knowing that he's just stuck with these fucking,
do they have any regular conversation with anybody?
I doubt you're thinking could walk along and pretend the cared about what
happened.
The coliseum last night about the potatoes or
the potatoes are no good.
We've gone to riots.
Shh.
We can fly.
He's drawn a fucking helicopter in his backyard.
Yeah.
That's so far ahead of the curve.
It's just,
it's,
but it stands to reason that some people are born with bigger dicks and other
people have larger ears.
Some people would just have a part of the brain or have the ability to tune into
creativity.
Yes.
Da Vinci's teacher,
it sounds like.
I mean was he was wealthy guy,
like did he come from a background where he had muscle?
No,
I did not know any of the history of monsters.
You didn't make any money at these things.
So you don't think,
when I was reading an article today that said,
you know,
even though human beings evolved about 200,000 years ago,
the first art,
the first signs of like religion or you know,
contemplated thinking didn't appear until the cave paintings that are like
70,000 years old.
So if we had had the same brains for 200,000 years,
but you didn't see the beginning of humanness or imagination until about 70,000
years ago,
why did it take so long?
If we've had the same rates and the idea is that we,
it's like Maslow's hierarchy of needs.
Those first hundred thousand years we didn't even have enough food.
We didn't have like any kind of organized society.
It was only when we could afford it.
The leisure time that all this other stuff came back.
A loan you mostly pay interest at first and then and then 1 cent on that pop on
the two lodge and then eventually you're paying like only two sheets of any
hilarity.
The rest of the ticket,
get it all they had,
they took 99% of their time just dealing with staying alive.
That to get to wherever they were going,
hierarchy of needs and it's like as a collective human society,
at some point we were able to,
we had enough hunters and we had enough organization maybe that we could feed
ourselves.
And there was at the beginning of free time at the beginning of eating
psychedelic chemicals and making cave paintings and semantic dances and all of
that free time is my God.
Think about countries today,
w civilizations today that I live in like that.
Have you heard about these people in India?
There's an island and uncontacted island off of India and recently these,
uh,
within the last few years,
these fishermen inadvertently got drunk in their boat and drifted into shore and
these people killed
them.
They killed them.
And then the,
the authorities are trying to figure out how to get to the bodies without
getting shot at by these people want to have him to kill them because there's
not that many lapses is maybe like 40 or 50 and they have no contact with other
human beings.
They are barbarians there total 100% complete savages that are living off the
land fishing with homemade Netscape.
What do you want them under it?
Just like they're controlling themselves who are usually put them under your
thumb.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's not only that,
they won't even go in there to retaliate against murder,
which is fascinating to me.
It's like they're,
the anthropologists are so concerned with keeping this intact and studying the
civilization in some sort of a way to try to get to see,
I mean this is really not that many lasts like their own country and they were
attacked.
Wow.
No,
no.
It's both some cash to board and they just kill the guys.
We talked to him first,
you know what I mean?
He might've been a respected member of the community within six months.
You know,
they didn't even give a chance.
Can you help me out?
I run us seems broken and these tales of cannibalism,
but um,
it's hard to substantiate but it's not outside the realm of possibility.
So you might be dealing with cannibals that we uh,
allowed to kill people because there so primitive that we don't want to fuck up
what they've got because there's only like 40 of them
I serve that isn't that interesting cause there is a sentimental instinct in
humanity and that wants to preserve everything in everything.
All the old hamburger place goes under Armour.
Yeah.
It's like an instinct that people want to do that.
And a lot of people say that's like,
you know,
that's part of our humanity is a,
is keeping intact cultures and religions and still be in tact.
All these ideas because they,
they,
you can see that with this thing that's emerging,
this thing that's emerging is so far is so much bigger than some old desert
religion.
And they'll bigger it gets.
And the more this thing emerges,
the more it's light begins to shine so brightly that all of these silly little
superstitious ideas begin to seem increasingly ridiculous.
I mean,
our consciousness is becoming so expanded that it's almost like,
you know,
we're able to like all of a sudden turn around and see ourselves and I know that
sounds almost like it's impossible shape,
but like the first time that we can actually do that and we can see ourselves
sort of out of context.
Just like in 1969 when astronauts first took a picture of the earth from the
vantage point of space,
I mean,
it's literally like the human mind was folding in on itself because how's it
possible for a human brain that emerged from the earth to then see the earth,
not from the euro.
You know what I mean?
It's like earth looking at itself.
Like that's what was happening because we are like a seed of the planet.
And then we left the planet and turned around and took a picture.
How about the Mindfox of the shots from the voyager?
From orbit?
Oh yeah.
You see Earth as like a pale blue dot.
Dot.
Have you seen
God?
Yeah.
Yes.
Amazing.
They sent something out there and it's still taking pictures of us and it's,
it's so fucking far away that were like a little tiny.
Dot.
And then you get a sense of what this thing really is.
Since sanity is insanity,
it doesn't even,
how do you reconcile himself though to that?
Like think
about the average person.
How do you accommodate to yourself,
to the idea that everything you know,
the vast expanse,
that repository of experience of your entire life is a blink of a blink of a
blink on a grain of a grain,
of a grain,
of a grain.
Like instead of turning that way.
I mean,
you don't matter at all.
Why not just enjoy yourself?
You do matter though.
That's not true.
You want it to mean something or want to fly.
No,
it does.
It does mean something.
It means something to you right now.
It's tangible.
It's real.
It means something that people do.
You're in contact with.
There's nothing unreal or unnatural banner because it's temporary,
but oh,
but do you have attachments where you don't have attachment?
When you do,
it's natural.
But there's this connection that you have to,
this greater gigantic thing doesn't negate the small moments in your life.
Right?
It doesn't negate video games that you enjoy.
It doesn't any gate finding like the perfect porn to jerk off to.
It doesn't negate a sandwich.
You Joy,
give yourself happiness until you're gone.
But I don't agree that it doesn't matter because it does matter.
It matters to you right now.
And although that seems ridiculous,
so does life itself.
So does every breath you take will hold your breath.
Stupid.
You don't,
you don't think the briefings important.
Hold your breath.
Of course it's important.
Don't be silly.
You're like this.
The existential ideas can overwhelm the reality of the situation and the reality
of the situation is you would like to stay alive.
And for the most part it's fun.
Yeah.
You know?
And if it's not fun,
you've managed your right,
your life and correct.
Well,
you know,
but you know what's interesting about what you just said is that you know,
you,
you've eloquently stated something that's actually very difficult for most
people to experience.
Most people either have to have like they have to be half asleep,
which means ignore the overwhelming universe and just just be barely present.
And then other people are awake to this overwhelming university courses that he
can hear you.
You're talking about him like he's done here.
He's jabbing it red band.
No,
we're not.
We're just bringing them in on the conversation.
It's like,
you know,
Albert Kemu,
the existentialists that life should be lived to the point of tears,
right.
Everything has been figured out except how to live,
and this is the question is it was in the onions and hot sauce.
It was just a freak like that.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
It was a big misunderstanding.
Onions and hot sauce,
hot sauce aficionado.
And everybody was like,
oh,
he's just like really deep.
You know how he died?
He had a train ticket that he was going to take a train to get to its
destination as friends are like,
no,
let us drive you.
And he got in an accident.
It's like a bad,
terrible decision.
But go on with the your commute quote.
Cause I loved that day before.
I can't remember my mother died yesterday or it might've been the day before.
I can't remember the stranger just disconnected,
completely blew,
like reading it.
And I find it really depressing.
I guess my whole question is,
okay,
so in the face of an infinite universe with our minds,
we can ponder something close to the infinite.
Yet the irony is that we're housed in these pumping,
breath,
gasping to king bodies.
You know,
Ernest Becker wrote the denial of death.
It says we are God's with anuses.
Think of how brilliant that is.
So the idea that we are these transcendent beings,
but every single day we are reminded that we have met at metabolism.
It's funny,
Becker thinks that God doesn't have an anus.
How does he know so presumptuous,
but how do you,
how do you reconsider as the only species that can really like lose sleep over
the fact that we are mortal beings?
You know,
we,
we can barely sustain the here and now because we know that one day we might be
dead.
And so what do we do?
Do we just lose ourselves and diversions and sex and drugs?
Here's my problem with this whole line of yeah,
here's my problem.
This whole line of thinking.
Yeah,
what does the average person do?
Was He always first to do?
How about turn the question inward and say,
what do you do?
And tell everybody what you do because that's how we figure it out through you
telling me how you're managing it.
I tell you,
but when you start going,
what does the average person to with the reality is we're all the,
we're all the average person.
The average person varies especially,
yeah.
Yes,
absolutely.
In our significance we are all the average and 100% yeah.
And when someone says it,
all men are created equal.
Not really,
but yes.
Not really in this experience,
You know,
there's Einsteins,
just Stephen Hawkings.
There's fucking,
Lou Ferrigno knows there's a lot of weird people in this world,
but they're there.
I think there's a responsibility as you,
as technology emerges in science begins to show us the truth of reality.
These are responsibilities began to emerge that create ethical dilemmas for our
societies,
which is when you have large swaths of the human population being controlled by
tyrannical fundamentalist religious people who are basing everything they do on
a,
a phantasmo being that clearly doesn't exist.
An outdated rituals that are,
are,
are just rotting.
Galileo,
apologize.
Yes.
What do you do?
Because in those situations,
at some point it's like,
well,
you do have a right,
you obviously there's freedom of religion.
You want to give people freedom of religion,
but simultaneously it's like,
well,
but why are you cutting girls?
Cliteracy is off.
You know what I mean?
It's almost like,
it's almost like,
you know,
we,
we need an upgrade.
You know,
like religion was a technology that at least informed people with the illusion
of meaning so that they could,
you know,
as I say,
you can live for a week without food,
three days without water,
but not a minute without hope.
You know,
like so that gave us hope and an Ernest Becker says that was the frustration for
a minute.
Yeah.
That was the first deliver said that never ate a pot brownie cause this fucking
hours with no hope
really had the other side.
You learn what you are doing something well that's interesting.
We talked about Iowaska and DMT,
which as Eric Davis says,
baseline reality dissolves.
There's a complete ego death and a new reality emerges or it just fucks with
your visual cortex and you add it all with your ego and your psyche and your
creativity and you just,
you have the ability to generate images inside the mines eye with your
creativity.
You just create a fucking
a world of geometric patterns because that's how your eyeball works when it's
over flooded with too much DMT.
That's how your visual cortex response.
What happens when there's 10 times the normal dose in maybe that just like when
you have a cut it clots.
Yeah.
But you know,
responds to them.
This is what I always say when people say,
how do you know whether or not a DMT trip is a real,
like what do you know?
Like you're pretending like that that really happened.
You really did speak with intelligent beings from the planet.
The reality is whether or not you really did go to another dimension and speak
with these super intelligent beings who are made out of love or whether it
didn't happen at all.
Either way,
you experience the same thing.
Right?
Right.
Sure.
You get to hear the message.
You get to see the exact same thing as if it was real.
Like literally,
well you know where that was explored brilliantly.
Do you guys remember the movie contact?
Yeah.
So she is a secular scientists.
She doesn't want to hang out with like,
you know,
Matthew mcconaughey who's a priest.
She doesn't believe in guide.
In fact,
at first they try not to see,
but see that's how brilliant of the Matthew mcconahey cock.
Cause even though she didn't want any of that,
he's still fucked.
Her son,
she risk pregnancy ended the movie,
she went right through the warm wool and went to the Saudis alien civilizations
had an experience that sounded like a religious experience except it wasn't,
you know,
she didn't go anywhere.
Well,
from the perspective of earth through the Wormhole,
it just looked like the ship,
just what ran right through.
Right.
So nobody believed her,
but she had the experience so that all of a sudden she was sounding like the
religious people are like the people that were tripping that said they saw the
Alps and all of a sudden she has this scientist was had to cast doubt on her own
experience because she,
we evidence you will try DMT.
You know already what that is.
It doesn't just hit.
You were like,
what the fuck?
And your mind just explodes.
You know,
you're taking something so you can make reason of it.
I could totally say like,
well what was it that must be God and let me tell other people about this.
Well,
you know the totally see that
Jerusalem,
legitimate scholars now that believe that that's what Moses saw when he saw the
burning Bush did.
He saw the Acacia tree acacia tree,
which is rich and DMT,
and it's really common to that area.
The idea is that this Bush or the extraction of this Bush was burning and that's
how he had this religious experience.
It's saw God dried a DMT trip and this is like,
this is nice.
I caught a puff of this tree like on fire.
That's one of the theories.
That's just a theory that,
but the primary focus is of achieving this theory is that Moses most likely had
a psychedelic experience because we know that these substances are not Nicholas.
He said he got the tablets that God gave him,
but he's smashed him before we got on the hill.
He was mad cause they made the Golden County.
Especially somebody of saw the fucking tablets.
Yeah,
he was tripping as researcher does.
Yeah.
He could have been like,
yeah,
so I smashed it.
All the above,
the evidence,
all the [inaudible] are you talking about a tie?
But that's very similar to when Terence Mckenna,
thoughts about the stoned ape hypothesis is obviously,
but there's um,
there's a guy called rich Doyle.
He wrote a book called Darwin's pharmacy and it's about sex plants and the
evolution of the newest fear.
He talks about psychedelic substances,
information
technologies that manipulate our ability to capture,
manage attention.
So they create what he calls infinite resonance with set and setting.
So in other words,
infinite resonance with set and setting.
That's why when people talk about like psychedelic experiences are like,
make sure you're in a good headspace.
Make sure you're a sense.
Because if you have infinite resonance with set and setting residents like your,
you become completely porous to whatever
Mumbo jumbo,
you no longer have the ability.
It's like turning,
it's like turning up the volume on existence.
Turning up the volume was so loud that if you're in a magnificent place looking
at a tree,
you might think you're looking at God.
If you're in an uncomfortable situation,
you're going to go down to the pits and a microphone gets too loud and you get
feedback.
If you're in a shitty place tripping,
you get a fee and that feedback just keeps going.
Or You could be in a beautiful place that elicits feelings of calm and serene,
this and then you can feel like you're like,
oh my God.
Yeah.
[inaudible] shrimp festival.
It's going to be the real happy shrimp fest.
This guy.
That's going to be the real problem.
When people are able to decide what state of consciousness they experience at
that moment,
not even her by being so scared that you take mushrooms because every time I'm
taking mushrooms I've been scared.
Should be you're about to go through some change.
Yeah.
It gets scary.
Why eat a pop quiz control?
When I,
when I eat the last [inaudible] pod cookie,
I'm like,
Oh shit,
that's happened my feet.
Why did I do?
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's true.
Now is that,
is that,
why is that?
Because it's like if you think of the metaphor of skydiving,
it's the moment we've already jumped
that there's an accelerating process of self development that we all go through.
Yeah.
And then if we are not improving as a human being,
we feel shitty.
We don't feel good.
I don't feel good unless I'm getting my shit together.
That's just a fact.
Um,
I try to be a better person today than I was yesterday for real.
And it sounds stupid,
but it's because everybody says it and very few people like legitimately totally
practice it.
They fall in and out.
But I feel like that's also one of the reasons why people aren't that happy.
I feel like if you not like improving yourself and,
and getting rid of your bullshit in life,
it's very difficult to feel good.
It's very difficult to be enjoying it.
If you have all these issues that you're not dealing with like a you as a
person,
are you with your job or you,
you know more and more people talking about it when they say like,
and I know I've been bad at that and I'm actually trying to get,
trying to make a note to not be like that anymore.
He's telling the truth.
I mean it's not a process where you know,
you either get it right or you don't get it right.
Like some people fall back and forth.
I mean,
how many people do we know that used to drink and then drank again and stop
drinking for a long time and then,
you know,
it's like a little battle sometimes with,
with people to try to improve their shit.
Ron doss compares it to floating in the ocean and your head's bobbing up and
down.
Sometimes you see the shore and sometimes you don't.
That's what it's like.
It's like sometimes you're there and you see it,
but you can't beat yourself up when you go down.
You have to have faith that you'll come back out.
But what you're saying is dead on man,
because if I'm feeling like shit,
it is what you're saying.
It's not some broad big thing you've got to do.
If I'm feeling like Shit,
nine times out of 10 it's just because I've got dishes in the sink or I didn't
go jogging or I didn't like sweet my kitchen.
It's not like big that.
But that would be like an example of set and setting right there.
I know other people say that,
you know,
99% of your problems will go away if you get a good night's sleep.
Like in terms of a lot of them do.
Yeah.
Where are we are sometimes,
you know,
even when you're sleeping,
you're thinking about things and you put them into perspective.
Yeah.
I mean,
how many times you've been really upset when you go to bed and by the time the
night over you're like,
yeah,
whatever.
Oh,
right.
You let it go.
Sleep on regulating your emotions a he lost or something,
something that happened.
Like,
I'm sure before you make the phone call,
don't worry about this because you've had a few instances where,
um,
like the amazing racist stuff like lost you gigs
in London,
Ontario.
Yeah.
That's gotta be frustrating.
It's frustrating.
How do you let go of that?
Like when you,
when you're dealing with something like that,
hey,
how do you let go of that?
Well,
sometimes you just like,
I,
I stopped myself.
I go stop.
Hold on.
Ken.
Griping about this,
change it in any way.
No.
All right.
Move on.
Moment of dialogue with yourself in a decision.
Yeah.
If I'm,
if I'm,
if I'm in a,
uh,
a long line at the airport and I'm gonna Miss My flight and I'm like,
I'll come.
I keep looking up ahead.
I'm like,
are you going to go to the front and asked,
hey,
I'm about to miss my flight or you're not,
if you're not,
stop griping and just let it wash over you.
I have a friend who was starting a company.
He wants to create a watch that regulates emotion.
Because we were talking about like creating,
if you were talking about the age of the quantified self,
where we're going to have all these devices that are going to be what emotion
that measures emotion.
If you're annoyed,
well it's not going to tell other people,
it'll tell you.
So we will send a code,
it will measure your biofeedback rhythms and it'll give you feedback to tell you
how you're feeling so that then you can change your behavior if that's what
needs to be done.
Feedback loops seems to be the best way to reprogram reflex responses.
Like they're saying that the best way to stop people from doing speeding is not
from like actually pulling them over,
but it's from those sensors that say your speed,
I'll tell you that as you pass him by receiving feedback is the best way to
change behavior.
So in terms of like moving towards experience design and the age of the
quantified self is if you know you're eating something unhealthy,
maybe you won't eat it.
If you're constantly reminded that you're feeling what you're doing,
you can really kind of improve yourself.
Like technologically enhanced mindfulness is what that is because it's like how
often are you wandering around in a state of absolute terror pretending
everything's fine.
Yeah,
totally fine having a great day,
but inside you're like,
oh fuck,
I don't make enough money.
I'm not going to make rent.
But you're pretending to be happy.
If you have a watch that's a bolt that's flashing,
like you're terrified,
you're tense right now,
you are tense.
Talk about it.
Deal with it.
The most important things that uh,
anybody could ever understand in this life is what happens and what it feels
like when you're out of debt.
You know,
cause how many of us,
how many of us hangs on your time or 20 whatever the fuck we are.
We have so much money.
We can't pay off
credit cards last week.
Pay Off my college loans.
Oh,
congratulations.
39 and that crazy.
What a crazy society we have that like everybody by the time they're 30 years
old isn't some kind of debt unless you're
super rich.
Out of a lot of uh,
education debt,
right.
A lot of education that's going to change with technological
medical debt.
That too.
Those are two systems that definitely need an upgrade.
I mean this is what we can actually connect that to.
The idea is that Ray Kurzweil is talking about,
he's saying that healthcare is about to undergo the same transformation that
information technology went through so that means that the whole idea of how
people you know cure themselves or fixed diseases,
this is all going to become like something that's a part of our smartphone and
part of our day to day life so it's going to change that broken system of health
care and education.
Also education through the Internet free education,
people around the world coming online in the global conversation,
getting free education.
There's a Harvard professor who's offering all those classes online.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
It's only the beginning of that and you have these in the power of decentralized
peer networks that can be leveraged to solve all these problems.
You know Steve's office,
Steve,
what does that mean?
Decentralized peer.
Now it's the same thing that we talked about.
Self Organization and emergence when like cells link up together and become
organisms.
So you haven't spoken to have electronic self organization happening like with
social media,
like when spontaneous,
when there's leaderless protests that just spontaneously self organized and
these technologies are allowing these decentralized peer networks don't have
leaders and don't have a head on cut cutoff potentially something like that.
But so Steven Johnson's book,
future perfect talks about how those can be leveraged to like solve problems.
You know like cure diseases,
like leverage
lies pure now
term because I think one of the big fucking problems is the need that people
have to claim responsibility for innovation.
And this is,
this is one of the horrors of our age is that that thing which makes people get
rich is what motivates people.
People aren't motivated.
Like when people are trying to cure cancer,
you like to believe that the reason they're trying to cure cancer is out of some
kind of altruism desire until you see them going to the supreme court to try to
patent genes because they want to profit off of their research.
Yeah,
that's pretty weird,
right?
It seems like the PR,
the ideas should be the the dream.
I know,
but that's why Pfizer is giving the researchers the money to research it so that
eventually they'll give you a little bit show return on that investment.
Right.
It's just a straight,
and you know what the real real
problem with all of it is that it's not psychedelic.
What's the real problem is that you can make money and create things and,
but you have to have a psychedelic mindset in order for society to move forward,
like emotionally or put a little behind a friendship wise.
Like if it's not doing that,
then it's going to get caught up in the ones and zeros collecting the numbers.
It can be prosperous and still be ethical.
It's just,
it's not.
And the reason why it's not as,
because the,
this,
when you have a corporation,
like you get that diffusion of responsibility thing going on,
which is the opposite of what psychedelic.
Yes,
absolutely.
Exactly man.
It's where the individual has no responsibility for the mass of individuals,
whereas the psychedelic experience,
massive individuals is connected entirely.
Yeah.
Joshua tree on Sunday.
Tell me what you're going to do this on.
Let me guess.
I think you're,
you're probably going to do your taxes.
You can get through mushrooms under the supermoon.
Get your freak on and they're super moon on Sunday,
Sunday night,
middle of shrimp fest and tell you something son.
When you do mushrooms supermom
no,
none.
Supermoon when you do mushrooms and you realize that there is a fucking planet,
one quarter of the size of ours and it's literally for loading above our heads
tent hotel room
out in Joshua.
Yeah.
I've never been there too.
She'll be cool.
Dunkin,
what are you getting buddy?
I'm talking about beer.
Try One of these black Butte porters there.
She lish.
Yeah.
Delicious.
I tried to check in with that 23 year old recently.
Those people that's straight out of college,
they're in training,
damn shots around like it's nothing.
And I'm barfing in the street and they're still going.
They don't grow food.
I can't,
yeah,
you're live results on,
it's almost over.
Have you ever had,
um,
Eric Davis on the show?
Eric Davis just wrote a book called Tech Gnosis then I think you guys would
love,
yeah,
he kind of writes about the mystical undertones of technology.
So again,
like the whole psychedelic cybernetics thing,
and I just,
I don't know.
I wondered if you guys ever had,
because he no,
never heard of him.
Yeah.
Now I know.
I've got this book guys.
Boom.
Sounds good.
It sounds like this perfect stuff right up my alley.
Yeah.
There's so many people like that now.
Thank you,
sir.
That's the beautiful thing about this time.
It's like,
you know,
every day there's some new guy who's got a new video or a new song or a new
fuck.
There's so many fucking pieces of something that are being created,
whether it's jokes,
more comedians now than ever access to all of it,
but there's also an infinite amount of content.
How do you decide what to pay attention to it?
That's one of the really hard,
well that's one of the things anxiety.
Well that's the beauty of something like a death squad where like,
you know what,
which was the stupid nickname and we all call ourselves like you know that if
Ari tells you someone's funny,
he's not going to be lying about it.
Right.
You know people that aren't funny.
No.
Yeah,
but that's good.
You've already tells me to watch some guy I know.
He's really funny.
So the audience knows that too.
And that's sorta like the beauty of having like a bunch of people that have a
likeminded.
You tune in and we're all different.
Like there's a lot of people that would hate our humor.
All right.
And the last thing they want to do is be hanging around with us and they're not
wrong.
They're just not into it.
They have a different thing,
you know what I mean?
But you find your thing,
whatever it is,
you know,
when there's Johnny Cash or Taylor Swift,
you fucking follow it.
And then,
you know,
whatever connected to her.
I mean those people are gonna find it for you.
Yeah.
I think that's how you do it in today's Day and age.
It's like,
and that's the beauty of us being able to introduce people like Bert Kreischer
or anybody else that we brought onto our podcast that all sudden other people
and go,
oh,
that guy's really funny.
Like,
oh,
and he's friends with this guy.
Oh,
that guy's really funny too.
And then people discovered was this was,
this was one of the biggest thing that has ever I ever did because my gas dude,
it's amazing.
It's been a year later and I still get people saying,
you like to come back and hang out with you guys and have a main drag,
which has been amazing.
Well,
it's a two way street though,
because the whole reason why the podcast is,
is interesting is because people like you are interested in coming on.
You know?
If you only had to just me talking after awhile,
I'd be repeating stories like a motherfucker.
I just be spouting nonsense at this point.
But you know what's interesting about what you're saying?
You know there's a book that talks about the importance of an information diet.
You know,
because we live in a world now where there is like an infinite amount of content
out there,
more than 10,000 hours of video uploaded to youtube every hour or some crazy
number like that.
And so the most difficult thing I think becomes deciding who we're going to be.
Your information diet filters,
like in this case,
the death squad,
the peer networks that you are connected to the people you follow.
Brian Writer,
by the way,
Brian Redman one is
leaving us everybody.
So he's got to go do a nice house show.
When is your new shirt coming out?
Preorders should be up next week.
So next two weeks or so.
My favorite of all time,
it's,
it's a head and shoulders.
It's awesome.
And the other one is awesome too.
But this new one is on another level.
It's dope.
I want it.
I want a pair of underwear on it.
I want a pair of underwear with that on Jesus Christ.
Fuck Dude.
I work cloth off over my Dick.
That's how I got on that pie cast show.
Jason,
what kind of car do you drive?
Dude?
Oh,
that was the,
I don't have a car anymore because one of those mother fuckers,
I'm in New York.
I used to have one here in New York.
You don't,
you don't drive cars.
I mean,
when I lived here,
I had a car.
I wanted to ask you about that Tesla.
Oh,
oh my God.
Is that the coolest thing of all times of incredible and they're only gonna get
better.
I think there were about to release like the third or fourth generation now.
Martine Rothblatt had one and when I interviewed her and I got to meet her robot
Bina 48.
Yeah.
You ever seen that?
Her know for spouses,
a robot chicken broth bought fascinating story was a man was a man,
uh,
founded Sirius satellite radio,
got a sex change,
became a woman and then created a robot that is a direct copy,
a duplicate of her spouse.
We'd be,
how good is spouse?
Well there she's there too.
She's there as well,
the bear.
So she made a robot for that.
So sweet.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
Liberace making that guy a,
his face to him.
Whoa,
you really do that.
They don't get plastic surgery to look more like Liberace.
That's hilarious.
He really is out in that the HBO thing,
I always wondered why Matt Damon and Michael Douglas were willing to do that and
like they have pictures of those two blowing each other.
That's the only thing that makes sense.
They agreed to do it.
Look like if they came up to you and you were,
you were mad when they said,
hey listen man,
I know those Bourne identity movies,
they were really big and blah,
blah,
blah.
Listen,
you're going to play Liberace cheese.
But buddy made for TV.
Yeah.
TV,
Liberace,
his longtime lover.
But it's very offensive,
by the way,
to my gay friends,
and I apologize,
but pirate,
you guys are so immature.
I mean,
if you said that a girl was your vagina,
pal does,
that'd be rude.
But Jain of power,
you know,
it just be embarrassed isn't interesting that a girl can call a Guy Dick and
there's no repercussions at all.
There aren't in my heart.
And she can even say a,
I'm hearing good.
Get some good Jason Silva,
Dick.
And you wouldn't have any problem with that.
You'd be like,
Yep,
I'm dishing it out,
honey.
But if a guy says,
oh,
I'm here to get some sweet Mary Pussy,
she'd be like,
what the fuck?
It's cause of the keepers.
That's who I am.
I'm sweet Mary Pussy.
You don't think that's gross?
And you're like,
oh my God,
you're not really,
my friend.
Can't even joke around with you.
Jason,
what do you think's gonna Happen with these checks?
Android's,
what do you see as the future?
Well,
I think,
I think the sex does sex technology will probably be the pioneer.
I mean just like with porn,
the porn industry,
Pioneer Dvds when DVDs were first a thing,
who do you think was doing the most advanced?
Like multi-angle interactive?
The experiences was the point of this.
I said phones wasn't going to go with that old style of video.
All the porn was like,
cool,
we'll have to,
yeah,
exactly.
I never did the rest of them totally.
I mean we're always going to be driven by sort of our sexual desires.
Kurzweil says we'll be able to tap into each other's nervous systems and become
each other when we have sex with a girl.
Finding with someone like imagine actually merges.
Well,
but no,
but some people say,
you know that come a suture talks about we've been wanting to merge with our
lovers.
It's the beginning of time.
I want to become one.
But imagine if we can actually scramble our nervous systems together because we
had an engine and demolition man device or whatever.
That can be a real mind fuck though.
If you just find out that you are like the worst in bed ever to be fucked by
you.
Shit,
look at me.
I'm this og,
why am I doing?
Wow,
that's going to be for 16 be
even better.
Take it.
I don't like it.
Take it over.
Like why am I choking myself?
I won't you let me breathe me.
Or even worse.
What if she get into her mind?
Like if you can access your girlfriend's needs and desires and you got,
I want to know what you want and you get into,
it's just a river of black cock,
sleepy river of disembodied black cops just shooting,
shooting sperm like a,
like a psychadelic dream.
You're binding a river of dark black coffee,
black caucus,
slippery red
bull.
Cox Do allow for a lot of creativity in sort of our,
our,
our sexual consciousness,
you know,
was on the side that's going ahead with a multiplicity of dimensions and we
can't even imagine it's the black psychedelic causation of sexualities that
every,
that drives most a lot of our technology lately,
but we still
have to repress it.
Societaly sex.
Well,
I think that still has to be like looked on as embarrassing reproductive force.
It's the drive.
It's the wind in the sails of humanity.
It's dre.
It drives me.
What's that?
But as you guys know this,
there was actually like a book about this.
It's called the mating mind.
It was written by Geoffrey Miller and he says that the brain's extraordinary
capacities for creativity,
for discourse,
for everything we do even build airplanes and iPhones is ultimately are
glorified version of the peacock feather.
It's our version of the song.
It's just us charming to capture and manage the attention to those potential
mates.
It's a way of saying I'm poetic,
I built that skyscraper or I wrote you the sows,
every joke and we comedians ever told everything.
What's interesting is that this side,
the side effect of this sexual creativity is also responsible for everything
wonderful we've created.
So it talks about thinking about sexuality ultimately as a creative act it is
cause it's about reproduction but ultimately on a cultural level and on a idea
sex level,
like the whole fucking thing about reproduction seems to be like,
all right,
we used that thing.
We're getting lured by nature and to making babies,
but now we see where being lured by nature and to making spaceships.
Singularity is a cosmic orgasm is the best way to describe what the singularity
is.
It's like universe waking up.
It's up.
It's awesome.
Impregnating the University of Intelligent McLuhan quote,
human beings are the sex organs of the machine world.
Wow.
Brilliant.
That's brilliant.
Marshall McLuhan nailed that shit in the sixth to the machine world,
like the machines are controlling our computers.
He figured that out before computers.
It was this actual genius.
He also said we build the tools.
Then they billed us.
Think about it.
That's happening.
That's true.
Of course it's happening again.
Much like Davinci.
What a mind.
Fuck.
It must've been to be operating like that back in the,
you know it's eventually also did he figured out how to draw curves,
how to draw a rounded edges and art like no one knew how to like make it like so
you have to catch it.
It's like to go around and loses frame.
You know how like a path I'll go until he was the one who,
I don't know if I remember from high school
and whatever that's attributed to him along those lines.
It was a good guy.
He put in his hours
because it's like,
well,
what aren't we doing now that will have like for grand,
we'll take for granted in a hundred years?
What do you mean didn't they didn't walk through walls
for time?
Yeah.
What a strange world it must have been back then,
man,
when you could just die if you got sick.
Most people just died.
They thought 50% children.
Completely.
And most people I know,
and there's a lot of people though today that think that the things are getting
worse in the world,
which is another one of those like mistakes that people are living longer than
ever.
We're living longer than ever.
And there's a guy called Hans Rosling who has these amazing videos on the
Internet that show every nation in the world by every measurable indicator of
quality of life has been measurable last a hundred years.
No,
but it just shows that,
you know,
contrary to what the media in which it bleeds,
it leads feeds us
because we have these overactive fear based Amygdala.
They only pay attention to what's wrong.
We failed to see everything that's going right.
Phasing Shit.
Really hot.
Newscasters telling you horrible things.
She's got big tits and I'm scared out of their mind.
My Dick is hard and I'm ready to run.
Like everything is together.
Yeah.
So rude.
You know.
Show me some of the ugly to propel you to tell me some bad news.
Tell it's like get my high school team or switch them in when they go.
And this is just an a puppy found alive and healthy.
Ah,
and then the big tits come out at a party.
Yeah.
But you could tell a lot about bill O'Reilly.
Like I promise you that Bill O'reilly loves getting tied up.
I can,
I can't say that for sure.
Like whatever legal stuff is I guess.
But I would imagine bill O'Reilly,
cause he's always like an honest show.
It's always these like beautiful,
yet dominating hot girls that surround him.
Like he likes to be around these types of girls.
He,
yeah,
he loves it.
He never see that the women around him on that show is being like submissive to
them.
They're always kind of tough guaranteed.
They scrub him down.
When you think about this email she wrote from down,
what are you thinking about bill O'Reilly all the time?
Do you imagine ever that you were some really fucking stupid guy like bill
O'Reilly,
a smart,
stupid guy.
He's a Harvard graduate dummy.
You know,
he's one of those guys.
I'm going to go with Jesus.
What did he say his thing about Jesus,
he's like,
Jesus,
I'm going to go with the Jesus.
Why is the tide come in?
Why does it go out?
Oh,
that Dawkins interview in doc and they'll look at that smile on Dawkins face.
It's a smile of the Lord of the rings.
Necromancer as he's crushing just like a,
a little emperor,
something.
It was just this like the look on his face because he's like
Dunkin's though from my tastes gets a little too upset.
What's that?
Yes.
For my,
for I don't have my super genius atheist,
reasonable people talking to cuco heads.
I like my,
uh,
my atheist to be a little bit more relaxed.
I think it,
I think it was a great reaction.
Shot him as Dawkins has got.
He's a little on the county side or smile like oh Riley deserves a co for sure.
Don't get me wrong.
But I think that Dawkins,
uh,
at his age is,
is such a statesmen,
such a,
a well respected is probably showing off too.
I am maybe perhaps,
and maybe also he feels it's his duty to maybe merciful,
you know,
to mercenary go after those guys cause he is the intellectual voice for the
atheist.
You know,
he's super important in that way.
I just wish she would chill.
And you know,
one of the things that I found out about him is no psychedelic drugs in his back
and he talked about how he maybe would be interested in taking LSD under egg,
very clinical setting to explore the merit to that drug.
You know what that says to me?
That's,
that's where the hole is.
That's where the holes in his game.
That's why it comes off country.
Because
another one of our atheist you for Sam Harris,
he has done psychedelics.
In fact he wrote an essay called psychedelics in the meaning of life,
which
was actually a very brilliant piece.
And for,
you know,
he's an interesting guy because he's an atheist,
but he has some radical insights about like,
you know,
spiritual,
subjective experience and where are things that come from Islamophobia.
I don't find that his writing comes across that way.
People argued that it does.
Uh,
he's a brilliant man and a friend.
I really like.
Yeah,
I very much.
Yeah.
Um,
and I really enjoyed talking to him because it's got such a fucking stupid smart
mind.
His brain is like firing like a brilliant million hurts.
Oh yeah.
But the,
the,
the thing about the,
uh,
the label of Islamophobe is like,
the reality is all ideologies that force people into doing violent things are
crazy and try to pretend that they're not to make some people who aren't violent
happy seems like intellectually dishonest.
And that's where the guy has has courage.
It's not Islamophobe.
Not at all.
He says Islam was Buddhism.
Okay.
Thinking about Buddhism,
and by the way,
this is a radical new sector of Buddhism.
Apparently that's like involved in like ethnic cleansing and so don't know what
you're talking about.
Oh,
they're fucking up Buddhism.
Like it's the last safe place after being a Mormon,
you know,
go to [inaudible] fault.
But I mean,
apparently it's Malaysia humans.
Humans are imperfect man.
I think it's something like that.
I don't really remember where it was,
but humans are so imperfect.
You know?
Th the I the idea that there's anything wrong with saying that ancient
ideologies that involve killing people if they don't believe her fucking bad.
Doesn't it say that somewhere?
Yeah.
We of course tell you you can't be tolerant of intolerance.
I mean,
that's the problem with moral relativism and we have this fear of like passing
any kind of judgment.
It's a different religion.
So what if they beat each other to death,
but don't let someone do something against someone's will to the hundred
percent.
You can't tolerate it.
Tolerance and behavior like that obviously isn't tolerance.
That's where the buck stops.
Bill Maher has spoken about this a lot of,
you know what's weird though?
Here's what's weird said.
Bill Maher.
Bill Maher gets labeled as in his Llama.
Phobe,
which I find fascinating because progressive's for some reason it's almost like
they're bullied.
So they want to make friends with the bully.
So there's this weird progressive thing where you don't criticize Islam and if
you do,
you become an Islamophobe.
Or if someone's criticizing other religions,
that's the first thing that they say.
Oh,
she criticize you never criticized Islam.
How come you never say shit about Islam?
So it becomes this weird sort of,
because they're so gangster,
you know,
they'll kill you if you draw pictures of Mohammed,
they take shit to the next level.
So the,
the natural inclination of the biggest pussy,
he's on earth,
which are the liberals for the most part.
They not only let them do it,
but support them.
You're Islamophobic.
You know Bill Martin is Islamophobe.
Guess what you should be.
You believe a phobe,
whether it's Ufo shows or big macabre is or Islam or
because you're against them raping little boys believe thing that you haven't
seen yourself are watched on TV.
You're an idiot.
Well,
this is the thing,
Joe.
This is a thing.
This is the thing you were talking about earlier when it,
and when it comes to the DMT experience of the psychedelic experience,
and the question is,
does it matter if this is real or not?
And I think it,
I think it matters more than anything.
If it's real,
we must,
we must understand reality from subjective reality.
We must understand if we can,
we should try to understand that.
For example,
um,
who was it?
I can't remember.
It was,
it was
only when it affects someone else.
It doesn't matter because it's,
it's the same experience,
but the experience is not a tangible rock solid carbon based touch,
a table experience.
The experience is this spiritual with the,
which I fucking hate to use,
but there's no other way to use a disembodied consciousness.
It's a disembodied consciousness experience.
Why would that be the same as an experience that's real?
That where you can touch pain.
Here's why.
If you take,
let's take,
I can't wear,
where does that people go to get healed?
Lords,
I think is what it's called.
But the water where,
I can't remember who wrote this,
I think it might've been Sagan or no,
it might've been fine man.
I can't remember which one.
Talking about how it's important to understand if this phenomenon is real or
subjective because cause if it's real,
then that means that we should understand what are the properties of these
waters.
Is it something in the land?
Is it's something in the air.
And if we can understand that,
then we can help the whole planet with us.
And the same way if the DMT or the psychedelic experience is taking us into a
state that is non subjective,
that is external,
is actually introducing us to entities or intelligence,
is that somehow exist outside of our own species.
It's incredibly important to begin to communicate with them.
And our real way,
if it is
what is real,
that's where it becomes when you're talking about an outside of the body
experience,
uh,
an experience that transcends the physical flesh.
It could still be real,
but not be measurable.
but you can't put it in a bucket and throw it on us.
It's not measurable.
I mean it's not really,
I think it could be a chemical gateway.
It could be something that we don't have an instrument to measure.
You don't have a conceptual framework understanding it's still real if it
happens.
That's one of my point is the idea of the imagination.
You imagine something,
the imagination is responsible for every fucking thing that a human has ever
made.
Sure.
Close this microphone that I'm talking to you,
this computer that I'm on is closing them.
Wearing the car that drove me here.
It's all manifest out of the imagination.
So imagination is fucking really shit.
100% and before you created those things,
when you just imagine them,
you were conjuring up something that didn't exist and the fact that we then
brought it into existence proofs,
well at at least existed as a potentiality.
Yeah.
It was allowed by the laws of physics.
So then it makes you wonder,
what are you tapping into when you were having that kind of vision,
that disembodied,
you know reconceptualization of reality.
We live in a world where there is no airplanes and you think that you could
build a machine that will fly over the ocean and get you to this other place.
Like to imagine that [inaudible] even fantasize about we can utter it means that
it's possible.
I mean,
does anybody even know how cell phones work?
But when you explain to me how a cell phone works,
look at stuff,
I dunno.
They swiped the card.
The card didn't card.
Wasn't Roddenberry though,
wasn't he?
I think he did that and then died.
Oh,
poor guy.
Yeah.
Well you had to predict,
but he didn't get to see the future.
I didn't get to say this way.
It's not on your rails motherfuckers.
I just think that if something,
if I think we should be mourning Roddenberry's likely there was a deep space,
nine,
he never saw the new Battlestar Galactica,
which is lucky.
Kicked his show.
Right.
And the,
Oh yeah.
I was going say was our track is so shit compared to Battlestar Galactica.
I never watched the problem you have every time you thinking like,
oh,
they're doing,
this is lame.
Within two seasons.
It'll pay off and be like,
oh,
Battlestar Galactica on the Scifi channel was the greatest Scifi show
dealt with in a real way.
Real life situations say with game of Thrones has whores,
you know murder up.
By the way,
how hot is that robot pitch?
The blonde one and one of the hottest I've take it burned holes in socks.
Oh,
the cylons.
The cylons become hot chicks.
That's part of the plot.
I don't want to spoiler spoiler alert if you haven't seen the DVD series,
you got to get that it right now.
It's incredulous.
Brian Kaplan told me about that.
I'm like,
that's going to suck dude.
It's a remake of a show.
That was kind of Hokey.
This show is not hokey at all.
All seriousness man,
because you're one of the busiest people I know.
How do you find time to watch Battlestar GALACTICA and breaking bad and game of
Thrones?
Like right now I don't have hardly any time.
Right?
He's already watched all star.
It was a long time ago.
You know when I was just doing like fear factor in the UFC,
I had way more time back in the days of breaking bad.
It just started.
Things were different back then while getting tattooed.
I watched like the first season while getting my left arm down,
right arm held my right arm.
I'm trying to catch up.
I'm breaking bad.
I fucking love it.
It's great.
So good.
You have to catch better.
Talk about it with homeland.
I heard that.
Was that watch season one?
It was.
I'm up to season two stunningly good.
Stunningly.
What'd you guys think of walking dead?
It's awesome and sucks.
It's the same shit.
Every time they resolve a conflict over the way they describe their emotions.
This gun,
it's all done.
The Guy,
the spoiler,
spoiler alert,
the bad guy,
the number one bad guy in the third season come.
You guys are teetering on the edge of fucking this whole thing up.
You need to regroup,
get together as a group of writers,
do some mushrooms and figured out where the fuck are you going.
You told me that,
that they had this other writers and they've
got really emotional for awhile and then they came in as said,
guys,
everybody get the fuck out and they hired like legit like action guys.
Here's the problem.
I think the problem is TV,
not the riders.
It's what TV tends to do to creativity.
If you read the comics,
the comics are some of the most bleak,
horrific things that you've ever seen where it's like every few pages is a gut
punch where you're like,
what the fuck?
It's not like this like emotional kind of sappy thing.
It's like you are existing in a world where you're going,
you are going to die probably eaten by the on deck.
Yeah,
that's what I was in apocalypse.
That was what was so what are you saying about that versus the world of TV?
Like I'm saying what happened because TV is like,
oh,
we can't make it too dark.
We can't kill that character because he was an established business model and we
have to keep some kind of stability in the system.
Stuff this up does make you a question to homicide.
Homicide.
Didn't last because it's,
I didn't have any clear cut victories for the good guys and bad guys.
I'm going to do a spoiler.
Is that why they call it programming?
Let me do it.
Not,
not win the series,
but with the comic books.
Can I do a spoiler?
Spoiler the comic books don't spoiler spoiler alert.
Spoiler alert boiler.
It's a spoiler to me and I'm not going to read the comics.
How dare you?
I,
you know,
listen to this fast.
I had comics on my iPad once on a plane
mercilessly
about the fact that I know why.
You know,
I can go,
well,
you responded,
you responded.
I'm like,
Oh,
I got him dancing.
A bear man.
Thought of myself as a twin.
Yeah,
you
were.
You were fucking dancing over the road.
That's pretty fucking,
you might as well just get punched in the face.
Just get kicked in the stomach.
I had to regroup for about a year also.
Also,
uh,
this is what movies sent me in the depression.
Where that anything,
which one?
Revolutionary Road.
What's that guy's brilliant dude.
Oh my God.
With DiCaprio and Kate Winslet.
And it was about,
it's about a married couple and it flashes back and forth between the banality
of day to day life.
Like what happens after you get what you want versus the hopes and dreams of
when they first met and then
read about the bushes.
It made you collide against,
against frustrated ambitions and a life of having to settle and settle and
settle and settle in to become a stale facsimile of what you find your dreams.
After that,
when they get excited about Paris is the best part of it.
You're just like,
Oh yes,
they're gonna move to Paris.
It's going to be a man,
Richard Linklater Foam.
They're going to be in Europe.
You know,
it doesn't happen.
Yes,
it's going to be awesome for you guys.
Get into it.
I want to give a report.
I'm going to report on what you've been looking on the laptop
during this thing.
Okay.
It's now gone from a series of videos of like weird vintage cars.
Porsches.
At one point he was just looking at what he called an accelerometer or you're
just looking at like a car accelerator.
Like the pedometer accelerating.
That was like five minutes.
You're building a car,
speeding and now you're looking at plot.
I don't know if you know this Dunkin,
but I'm crazy.
I'm looking at people playing pool.
I have an add that you couldn't publish class and I need no rhyme or rhythm to
it.
I need 13 different things going on with the drums of war pigs.
I have no sense.
I am what I am son.
Do you want to see it a two minute,
a two minute trippy video?
Yeah,
it's a new video says we are already,
cyborgs is kind of about the stuff from the conference we were just at,
let's pass that joint around before
Chad.
Thank you.
Oh yeah.
We live in a world of abundance.
Yes,
thanks Joanna Studios,
the new Roman Empire for weed.
Fuck Dude.
We're more like vomitorium.
Did you ever go to one of those?
Uh,
vomitorium they exist.
They just showed the old ones and like in Israel they show you where you'd have
to go to vomit and they come right back to partying and they left out the part
about fucking kids.
But I'm like,
I don't,
what's it vomitorium and party and drink.
Just keep going and going.
He's like,
oh,
I can't eat anymore.
You know,
that moment was that kid anymore.
You go to this room,
we just get to vomit and then come back.
It's like a urinal,
but instead of peeing you're just vomit out as much as you can have the booze
and the food and you go back to drinking and eating.
Yeah.
The Romans supposedly did it with feathers.
That was the,
the,
you know,
really
Romans wanting to party so hard that they were willing to just eat as much as
they want it to and then throw up so they could eat again.
The way it's cough,
things of living forever.
They thought of partying forever.
Well it's also because mortality was such a high level back ever.
Presence and mortality is 50% people were dying left and right.
And sword fights.
I mean it was,
that was some crazy ass times.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But how much different is that different shit.
Emergency,
like set up a free tee shirt.
Oh is it?
Let's say higher primate Dotcom shirt available at [inaudible] dot com there are
also great for mop it up.
Spill.
You can mop up booze room wash right off those salt crystals are great man.
I gotta get some of those.
They're cool.
If you want to Bang Yoga teachers,
if you had a house and it was totally set up like a,
like you were like sot nom come into my presence.
You had a home on the wall and like these are your bed dude.
You're in and all you need is like some quote from some really obscure Indian
guy on the wall.
Like,
oh,
he's my guru.
I just know a video of Dunkin playing behind the boat.
Oh,
Duncan gets to start singing my apartment.
I'm ascribing his apartment to a tape.
I'm trying to fuck with them.
My stuff.
I can get accident,
sing them songs.
You could sing you,
you have chance in your head.
Oh God.
Give me another one.
The,
when I'm chanting right now is a,
it's a great chant because it sounds exactly the way a nitrous oxide sounds when
you do nitrous oxide.
If you chant it long enough,
it's the sound of Om when you get super high,
and so the Chan has our am Rom.
It's simple.
So the chant just goes,
yeah,
rum,
rum.
You're hearing the old myths that your hearing is your brain cells committing
suicide by swim,
you're hearing your dance,
your hearing,
your brain cells tap dancing give you like brain damage or just a short amount
of time.
I'm pretty sure sweat.
It's the same thing to give you.
I'm pretty sure going to the dentist is not good.
You're right about that,
but that's
pull great chance that you could do it anytime.
Oh,
wrong,
wrong.
Do that.
Crazy.
When you have memorized.
That's what I'm talking about.
You know that whole,
Oh my God.
That's a chant that goes a
[inaudible] extra and Tommy not decimate your,
you gotta have an ma.
She just,
Tonya,
I'm on obesity.
[inaudible] everybody to calm day.
I'm sure you could road show your top it all come along,
I'm sure eager to invite.
And I have,
I'm Josh Reed with palms created a ta so I do not going to Tommy Tom Tom saw to
be,
but be Tom said Shit.
Do you still do that thing where you put the business?
I lost that way.
That's amazing.
That's a chance that you say at the beginning you would,
you might pray a fewer into Bhakti Yoga.
You are prayed that into you,
your pray that prior to reading the Bhagavad Gita.
And that's a prayer that is,
um,
basically,
uh,
you were,
um,
the,
the first verse is very beautiful.
It goes,
I was born to the darkest of ignorance,
but my spiritual master opened my eyes with a torch of knowledge,
which I love that I love.
But it's like basically the idea is like,
um,
when you come into contact with truth,
which is what any of the sutures are by the way,
that I love the bug of,
I get it.
But I just started reading the Yoga Sutras of Patanjali,
which are fucking great man.
They blow the Bhagavad Gita out of the water as far as I'm,
you can find a pretentious at all.
What the,
the second thing,
I forgot it.
Sorry.
Yes,
I think it can seem pretentious and I think that people can use it as a tail
feather as you mentioned.
And I will fully admit that I've used it as a tail feather a before,
but I think in the same way that you were talking about how like reproduction
kind of lures you into creating robots or advances society in the same way.
I think people get drawn to philosophy for reasons that are just like,
well,
this will make me seem smart.
And then he,
uh,
on the one hand,
but also the tail feathers.
Yeah,
don't worry about it in other people.
But what's crazy about this stuff is that once you get into it for weird
reasons,
but once you get into it,
then it starts,
it starts deconstructing you.
It starts breaking you apart because it's going to this very micro level of the
way that we tend to work subjectively,
which is what,
but that's an objective experience.
There's only thing that ultimately matters,
you know,
in terms of your interior world,
right?
I mean,
you,
you talk about truth,
I think it was Verner Hertzog documentary film maker that was talking about the
difference between Ecstatic Truth and factual truth.
And he said,
you know,
if facts where the most interesting thing in the world,
then the phone book would be the world's most interesting book.
But obviously there's this other experience that we still called truth.
Maybe it's italicized or whatever it is,
but it's that ecstatic truth.
It's subjective truth.
It's the truth of the poet.
You know,
the journalist may be more accurate in describing the facts of an event,
but a poet may never brought deep and found the way to overcome the spurs.
Whatever it is.
The poet would reveal deeper truths if final place in the other's literal grids.
Well,
this is the Werner Herzog something interesting cat.
Very interesting.
Oh,
I fucking love it,
man.
I just saw him in spring break.
Oh wait,
no,
not spring breakers.
What I seen when he played a villain,
no,
Jack reacher,
yeah,
he was great,
but it wasn't a weird mills.
It's got that mill guy.
He's a good actor.
It's a great actor.
Which is weird.
Yeah.
I love Verner Herzog,
man.
He's the,
she would really love to get him off the record to give his opinion on grizzly
man.
Whether or not he knew that he was making a comedy.
He knew,
he knows no Verner Herzog knows he's making comedy.
Cause then all of his documentaries is an element of comedy and mocking the
person that she is smart enough to know what the person watching his movie,
his thinking.
And he knows when he,
when he does this stuff,
he knows that we are thinking this has got to be a comic Verner Herzog.
It's hilarious that if that's the case and cynical in that sense,
then that might be grizzly man might be the greatest creation of comedy.
Real subtle.
It's a wonderful comedy.
So subtle and so goddamn brilliantly crazy.
It's so,
it's wonderful.
It like celebrates people and all our wackiness and there's like a certain
comfort in watching a film about a guy who was completely off the rails that's
living with grizzlies.
Yeah.
Like it is.
We,
you know,
we might not like it,
but it makes us feel better about ourselves,
man.
And we,
we got a guy who's way more fucked up than us and makes us feel better about
ourselves.
Did,
but did you find them also kind of fascinating because I,
fuck,
yeah,
it was actually fascinating because that's the thing about when you watch a
movie,
I mean part of what happens when you're watching a movie is the same thing.
They don't rem when people,
when they,
they done an MRI scans on people.
When they watch movies and they say it,
it's very similar to when you're dreaming.
So the self,
that kind of the self awareness disappears.
And so that's
why you're able to like become the character that you identify with.
They call it the didactic shift when you assumed the viewpoint of one of the
characters.
So you watch a film like grizzly man,
it allows you to actually enter the consciousness perhaps with this person.
And that's what the whole thing about cinema,
it allows us to do.
That's why I feel like that might be fascinating for the shift.
Again,
dialectic shift,
love that term man.
Because enlightenment is the ultimate shift,
which is where you do the didactic shift.
You assume the viewpoint of the whole to the whole.
That's the idea is like we are always on the precipice of this final shift.
You are terrified to make that shift because we want to be an individual.
And the idea of going backwards,
that one time of taking off the neurological VR goggles,
the sociological VR goggles,
the consensus trends,
that cultural operating system,
you don't want it easier to become another person in the movie than it is to
become the whole training.
It makes my heart race.
It's terrifying,
but it's,
I would,
the reason I did it is because I love movies a lot since I was a little kid.
I would watch movies and one of the coolest experiences that you became Indiana
Jones,
like for two hours know Indiana Jones.
We're finding the right.
So what is happening?
Like how come sometimes you become the movie and other times you don't and when
you don't like life sucks,
right?
Right.
Like,
Oh,
I'm watching this movie.
It's not sucking me in.
And I wanted to study that and they say that,
you know,
movie watching and dreaming or strangely familiar exists faintly familiar
experiences,
similar experiences,
but apparently it has to do with your self awareness.
The lateral prefrontal Cortex,
the same thing that turns off when people are in flow states,
when rappers or freestyle,
the self editing this self consciousness disappears and we love transcending our
self consciousness because it's the moment in which we see that there's an
infinite amount of subjective experiences that we can have.
We can be Indiana Jones,
we can be,
you know,
anybody we want,
we're not bound by our individuated state,
which has amazing as it is.
It's still limited.
Is that lateral prefrontal frontal cortex that you're talking about?
Is that the neo cortex?
It is that in like as the neo cortex?
I have no idea.
It's the,
it says lateral,
so I imagine it's on this side,
but this is the reason I saw this as,
because it was talking about it in the article about movies and you blurring,
blending into the films.
But also another article was talking about flow states and when they did Fmri
Scans on freestyle rappers verses memorized and it was like the same thing.
But this is a terrifying thing for people.
That flow state that you're talking about.
If you have identified yourself with a level of suffering or with a level of
control or with a level of always being the thing driving the car in this flow
state,
you're talking about as a form of death,
you don't want to be there.
A lot of people,
the people who are stuck in bad are the ones who are,
uh,
the most wanting to be in control.
The people who have the most awful marijuana trips are always the control
freaks.
But think about it,
the reason that movies are so good at is because first they sit you in a really
comfortable place.
It's a comfortable seat.
You're in the dark,
the phones are off.
They make sure that you are comfortable so that they can ease you in.
And when the movie starts,
you're still yourself.
You're still fidgeting,
you have to pee.
But as soon as it starts,
they guide you with music and the set and setting informed the direction that
your consciousness is going.
And before you know what you're on a ride,
like the roller coaster has started and all of a sudden you forget yourself,
you are the source.
And then at the end of the day it becomes the most,
the best experience ever,
right?
Because when the great movies done,
you're like,
wow,
that was awesome.
I don't know where I went,
but I loved it.
Right?
Right.
But when the movie sucks,
it was a really unpleasant experience.
So we'd love losing ourselves,
but it's also what we were most terrified of.
So this is the idea that when we die,
the exact same experience happens where you're like,
holy shit,
maybe that was fucking amazing.
I thought I was
maybe hitting right.
Well,
maybe it's just an extended period of dreaming.
Maybe it's a movie where the doors becomes a dream state of 80 years.
That's why the movie inception is still brilliant when they go into limbo.
Limbo was 80 years aren't in life to be one of those limos that we forgot that
we decided to go to sleep.
We could be in the dream with the dream.
Didn't really lock me in.
I don't know why you should have been more high when you saw it.
Oh,
maybe.
No,
I wasn't understood.
Inception was,
I think inception.
I was a,
was a little like Wah.
It was a little too or find it was a little,
you had to follow it a little too close.
He's a little too much and he was explaining it to you.
Makes cube or something.
I'm sure you liked.
I'm sure your mind likes that.
I like,
you know,
it wasn't like the Matrix,
which is sort of a more of a visceral thing,
but it's still,
they're both pointing to the same idea,
which is that whatever your experience of reality is,
may in fact just be a dream state or some kind of hallucination or an aspect of
a simulation that you've become absorbed.
You know,
it's interesting you mentioned that because I actually brought
something to read to you guys about the Matrix,
so I'm going to load it up.
Oh cool.
And it's exactly about this conversation we're having.
It's almost like I thought at some point we're going to start talking about
blending into movies and breaking the ego and that whole thing.
So I'm just going to load that up.
Killing the person that,
uh,
the brothers had made the majors do.
Remember that the whole time she lost.
Then she really,
there was a settlement.
Maybe there was a settlement.
Yeah,
I think I remember that.
Yeah.
That never means anything does it right sometimes means you didn't want your
lower back.
You're just bored of dealing with it.
Sometimes it's fast.
You're going to win.
How about we just stop this right now?
Sometimes it's that too.
It's different things.
You never saw them never,
you know,
maybe she had an original idea and they took,
they took it to a different place,
but maybe they can trace the origin for that idea to get the fuck out of here.
Who is this?
There was a woman who sued the brother or brothers.
Brothers.
Siblings.
Yeah.
Boy Alerts.
Lame Larson.
You're just going from memory on that.
That'd be great if you've got it right.
Why won't the story about Sophia Stewart in their bone Matrix Matrix?
Let's hear it.
Okay.
Let me read you this while you search for that.
So this is article by Eric Davis and he's talking about Descartes and the and
the fee
and the false reality genre of filmmaking.
So films that reveal a crack in your reality,
the possibility of a hidden door of a rabbit hole to fall through.
And so he says we do you know that scene in the matrix when he's in the hotel
room and they are about to give him the pill?
Yes.
Okay.
That's the craziest part of the movie.
So he says,
we too are in debt,
decrepit hotel room with Laurence Fishburne is Morpheus who is really speaking
to us when he addresses neo.
The ever wouldn't canneries.
You know something.
What you know you can't explain,
but you feel it.
You've felt it your whole life.
You felt that something is wrong with the world,
you don't know what,
but it's like they're like a splinter in your mind.
And establishing that itch,
which I suppose most of us share,
however we interpreted Morpheus offers to scratch.
He will give Neil nothing more than knowledge of the truth.
I he no solutions to the problems posed by said truth.
And then it goes on and he says like a serpent in the garden of Eden,
which uh,
which,
okay,
so hello.
Morpheus offers neo a pill like a,
like,
uh,
like the serpent in the garden of Eden.
Morpheus offers neo a pill.
Neo of course,
swallows the molecular package,
which is really the most heroic act in the film for Neo must then pass his own
car Tz and passage through madness melting into the mirror that alludes not only
to Lewis Carroll but to the mystic psychotic collapse and disappearance of the
externalized ego that stabilizes our inner voice as neo phases out of the
matrix.
He opens up however briefly the fractured Bartow.
That is the secret thrill of every fan of the false reality genre,
the moment when baseline reality dissolves.
But no new reality has yet emerged and it's pixelating wait.
Okay,
cool.
That's great man.
I mean the fact that Eric Davis reads this deeply,
Phil,
that's why you guys got to chat with,
yeah,
so let's listen to the store.
Tell the case she was dismissed when she failed to show up for a preliminary
hearing of her case.
So that can mean one of two things.
You don't even mean she's crazy or they paid her to not show up.
No,
they,
she would just like,
no,
they made a settlement with her off the record.
I think they don't just not show up and scare the shit out of her.
And I told her not to show up.
Something happened.
She didn't show up.
I think maybe she had no case at all and she was just,
I just realized because crazy lawyer.
Oh,
that's right.
The angels.
God God.
Yeah.
I was his lawyer.
He,
I had to go.
I had to get a lawyer to go to court.
How long were you in court with that thing?
But a year.
Are you kidding?
Yeah.
How many times or no,
you are good to keep responding to keep responding to them.
He sued me for being a false prophet and no,
no,
I'm sorry.
He wanted us,
he wanted us to point.
Yeah.
And it,
and uh,
uh,
being a bad lawyer,
um,
and the better business bureau came after me.
So you lost the case?
No,
this girl Lisa helped me fight the case and had to show her he was suing me for,
um,
all the riches in the world.
And then when they,
when the,
she had to read it to the judge,
like,
this guy's crazy.
She's like,
what do you mean because we need that.
And she did the judge read and he was like,
oh,
it's that.
They made them rewrite it and it goes,
okay.
That $800 billion was what he's doing richest in the world.
Like leaves a lot on the table,
a lot of room for negotiation.
I mean,
assuming that you're going to continue to be more successful.
He did promise me though,
when he did eventually become king of kings,
he could repay me with,
um,
untold riches.
King of kings is a big,
big title for a,
a guy living in a homeless shelter.
Him Pro Bono.
I love this guys like levels of riches.
He has all the riches in the world,
but that's exceeded by untold riches.
All the riches in the world's more well then if you pay him all the riches in
the world and he pays you back and untold riches,
you're getting ripped off.
Yeah.
It's a bad before I denied him.
Why he's not really paying you back.
He's just giving you a little bit of what you guys give me some for helping
them.
That's,
that's about right.
You're just saying riches are confined to the world.
Rei Disagree.
Oh,
untold riches could be all the riches and
me as an attorney,
oh,
I'll hire you to represent me and I would have been a mayor,
was her name fake attorney Dunkin represents fig attorney Ra being sued by crazy
guy.
He kept trying to use big lingo because I would sometimes,
so we'd be like,
where to four awesome.
The plaintiffs who are attacking me,
he had,
he also wanted us to San Diego State Hospital.
I think they really fucked him up.
I think it got this like where they're really fucked him up.
Yeah.
I think he wanted us to do with that guy.
Right?
Dean Dean
know who talks to the dead.
Dean.
Dean [inaudible],
Dean Edwards.
John Edward.
John Edwards.
Demers is a comic cause it was just like the guy ran for president.
Dean Edwards.
Yeah.
And I remember saying like,
well why would he said he wanted to sue him for being a false prophet.
And I was like,
why would you get that money?
Hey wait,
can I change the subject for talking logical,
the crazy guy check for two seconds.
You're talking about just cause we were talking about Rich's outside the world.
Yeah.
It's media or harvesting thing.
Do you know about this free resources?
Oh yeah.
Peter Diamandis is behind it.
Dude.
They just launched $1 million Kickstarter project to create a space telescope
for public use because you know,
they're launching a whole fleet of tiny space telescopes to scan for near Earth
asteroids that we can then land on and leverage for resources.
Hold back in mind.
Typical one has like $1 trillion worth of plutonium,
for example.
That's why they're doing it.
They're not doing this.
When they,
when they're talking about NASA wants to grab an asteroid or a medium,
it's a media or an asteroid.
Asteroids,
asteroids,
when they say this,
you know they're not doing this.
You know,
it's not just scientific reasons.
They don't just want to harvest riches beyond all previous limits,
but it's that cake cause that's just an unscented.
It can really pull it off and that's why they would go do that.
That's why there's technologies and those thing so that somebody can make money.
And then how do they know that they plutonium in those things?
Oh they know,
they know that.
They know the chemical composition.
A filter can make estimations about what Jupiter
is composed of.
I mean that's kind of insane about humanity.
We can actually use our brains to extend our sensory apparatus.
Me On earth.
What's the mechanism of a determining the contents of an asteroid and you don't
know how they knew it?
The last few elements I paradox table.
They knew how much they'd way this.
They knew where they fit in and that chart,
they were like,
we haven't discovered them but we know exactly what they'll weigh and how would
their masculinity of the human brain to acquire such knowledge about the
building blocks of the physical world.
What does that say about us as like this unique for me into that group and that
Shit's preposterous.
I don't even,
those aren't even related to me.
Those are totally different kinds of animals.
Those people that have figured that out,
I don't think they are because the fact that we can have this conversation means
we can acknowledge some kind of understanding of what we're talking.
I mean I think that child is a child like understanding comparison to the dude
who figured out what a cork glue on plasma political the way and then made it
made something that if you get a sugar cube of it will fall straight through the
center of the earth because of the way like 400 billion pounds or something
fucking tray.
It's a different kind of animal.
You think there's a lot of different kind of brand you think?
Like if we went and sat with him for a couple of weeks,
he could explain it to us.
Like normal terms,
while people are remarkably adaptable and people go down certain paths,
I think in life and if you meet a guy who's like been a ballet dancer since he
was four years old and now he's 25 and doing these twirls in the air and Shit,
you would look at that guy moving,
I don't know why I chose ballet dance,
but you would look at that guy and moving,
they're going like,
that guy is so far down the path.
I could never possibly catch up.
Right?
But I think you could do ballet,
human beings,
human beings have a capacity for continuing down a path in a very far way to the
point where they're almost unrecognizable from when they first started and
insane specialization,
like a malleability trends.
Martial arts especially.
It's amazing how you can see that about let's say a ballet artist dancing and
stuff like,
well,
I can never do that.
And you could easily say,
there's no way I could,
but everybody thinks they can do stand up and that's funny with no training at
all that you find that they don't,
they don't really know what we're doing.
It's like they think they were just telling jokes and we absolutely are,
but it's all about where to put them.
How to Sam [inaudible],
I think they're hired philosophers.
They're up philosophy.
It's also hypnotism because there's some weird thing that you're doing where you
can get them in and the way you're lowering your voice and you get them tuned to
the way you're thinking by giving them shit that they want to listen to and if
you can find that rhythm where it's,
it's a thought that they would entertain themselves,
then they'll allow your mind to work for them because like,
oh,
this guy's got a very aware mind.
I'm,
I'm curious to hear what,
how he looks at things.
I'll allow him to thank for that.
The same thing,
presidents then comments,
then a big plugging into you.
The same way when you watch a movie,
you become the character in movie.
Those people are plugging into you at that moment.
When you enter that flow state,
do you feel like a conductor in an orchestra like literally like you move
orchestra?
That's exactly how it is.
Yeah.
It's like you guys were in a flow.
You become in sync,
so right there is interesting.
It's happening.
I don't know if we can even measure
that.
Like when people sync up like that,
whether it's lots of people to one person or lots of photos,
lots of other people like his gal for that.
You don't have a scale for that feeling.
I think you can study the way that a metallic particles react to magnets.
I think you can shit the way sound waves affect water and we use those
metaphors.
We say he's so magnetic,
it's on stage.
I mean use those metaphors to explain something for which we have no
instrumentation or way to quantify or measure.
Yet we employ those capacities.
We use those capacities.
We pay people millions of dollars because they're charismatic.
Well,
how do you measure charisma?
Is there a little machine that measures it?
Like radiation?
He has 97 Kelvin's of charisma.
Who,
so we employ these things but we can't measure them.
They exist but we can't measure.
It can focus attention and attention is a specific pattern of neural activity.
So the idea is that you have this group of people and you are transforming their
neuroactivity to match some intention that you have.
Whether it's because you want them to listen to your speech about hotels don't
like,
don't you wish there was like a special light you could use the could show the
energy
bridge and we can see the cell phone signals going through us right now.
Like if I can see how your my attention and catch a group of people dancing who
are all on ecstasy and what you are looking at the white fishes fish move around
a coral reef or look at yes,
you see this exact same undulating hidden order.
Just thinks,
well there's an essay due to called virtual reality and hallucination written by
Diana Slattery on reality sandwich.
And it's all about that.
She says the capture and management of attention is a vital component.
A state of immersion and state of absorption is a vital component in any kind of
interpersonal transformation or education or influence of any capacity or
growth.
In other words,
you need to be completely sucked into whatever it is that's going to really like
transform you and get inside of you.
Yeah,
so it all has to do with the capture and manage management of attention and what
our psychedelics,
if not attention,
technologies,
rhetoric,
what is language if not a technology to capture attention and shift any
discipline as a cycle,
a psychedelic experience and the long haul because disciplines transform you.
Yes,
yes,
yes and they focus attention,
attention.
Paul Fish and you just want people to put the laundry away while they were
watching.
Just not full of Shit.
Just look at it.
It's all he wanted was so he'd get lost in it.
You got people on your sourcing.
Attention is the key to everything.
If we had the power to decide at any given moment to focus our attention on the
best possible thing that we could focus our attention on,
my life would be like a living,
breathing sculpture.
It would be like a dream,
like constantly
jerking off in the new socks.
But think of Alec,
how's it sounds like a dream world.
Think about how I profitable,
being able to grab people's attention is,
and it's everything.
It's everything.
It's the currency of this new age.
Attention.
Attention is the new limited resource.
Yeah.
Attention is the new oil in a world of social media,
of infinite media,
infinite channels who succeeds,
but the one who was most physically able to capture and manage attention.
And that's where you see the phenomenon or something like this.
You guys,
I'm always talking about like you know,
it's been a year.
People are still saying come back and have this conversation.
I mean that just means that you've tapped into a nerve that millions are feeling
and when you consider that 10,000 hours of content is uploaded to youtube every
hour,
they,
you still have millions of people that come in and join.
This conversation shows like the power of that.
Like it's like,
it's like,
you know,
shining a little bit brighter than the other 10,000 hours.
But it's a funny thing when the surgeon doesn't tune in.
Like when you see Obama in Germany recently,
do you see that shit?
This speech he gave?
Ooh,
it's creepy.
That's like Alex Jones level creepy German pension.
Well,
no,
not aside from the fact that there was only like Latin,
the first time he came there,
it was packed hordes of people came to see him.
This time it was sparse and empty.
But what was really creepy was his echoing message about how we have to give up
freedom for security.
And you hear this coming out.
It's like Obama was saying it.
Oh yeah.
He was saying he was fucking sticking up for the Goddamn man.
I say,
because this leaky pull up the up,
Jeremy,
you find that it might be a long speech,
but it was Suki is out there,
bacon and the heat sweating and giving this,
this proclamation of how there's a balance between sick.
He was just talking about the importance of the security state.
And by the way,
you know,
there's a logical part of my brain that considers the what they're saying.
I have to allow myself to give consideration to saying,
you know what I mean?
But there's another cause.
Well especially cause I'm thinking,
well if this allows them to stop somebody from blowing themselves up in the
subway.
Yeah,
cool.
You know what a pickle urine,
what a pickle you're in.
If,
if,
if you do,
if you know that if I have this much,
uh,
width when it comes breadth,
when it comes to monitoring,
then I can stop people from getting blown up.
What happened at the Boston Marathon.
I can stop a kid from getting turned into fucking hamburger meat.
So now you're basically saying,
well,
what do we do here?
Are we going to just do we just say,
okay,
well I guess the cost of People's privacy,
is that from time to time children get evaporated or do you say,
no,
we've got to grow up to the fact that we're an interconnected system where all
cells in a bigger organism,
it's time.
We don't want to give up a secure,
I don't think the price is worth it.
We can't trust the government.
Not only that,
I think we're looking at the thing and correctly.
I think the thing that they should be concentrating on is the mental health
issue.
Yeah.
What?
What makes people willing to lash out and kill large numbers
instead of instead of [inaudible]?
Where do you think you can do with that you can invest in,
in research for mental health and you would solve a lot more mobile?
No,
when babies are born,
essentially,
we know we have,
we have birth certificates.
We know where people were living on social security numbers.
Why can't we find out whether or not people are doing really bad?
Well,
it's hard to find out whether or not people are losing their minds.
it's hard when they're in Yemen,
not meaning,
even in America,
we can't find out.
I think we do not have an accurate account of our citizens yet.
We could pretend that we're some sort of a community,
but we don't have an accurate account of the of our citizens.
When Zach told me they weren't gonna cover my mental health anymore because of
some type of Obamacare that went into action.
Oh,
you can't carry,
everybody can't carry them.
Also,
only plan one gets a plan to gets none.
Oh my God.
I was like,
I hope another Jared lauffner goes into your building and shoots.
Yeah.
What'd he get pulled every right after that?
They're going to pull everyone's mental health insurance.
Yeah,
because that crazy guy lost his health.
Well,
that's what you're turning us all.
If one of us is going to do that.
But let me ask you something.
Do you think that when a person who uploads like that,
if we're talking about what happened to that person on like a human scale,
we might say,
okay,
well maybe you know,
years of disaffection and radicalization and propaganda and mediation from the
wrong influences in his focused attention on the wrong place until he's old
personality could be a real issue,
medical issue.
But let's,
so let's zoom out for a little bit and think of that person as a cell in the
bigger organism.
Is he like a cancer cell?
Is he the equivalent of like when a cancer cell starts to like replicate without
concern for the rest of the sales and the system?
I mean it's that where is it a broken thing?
Could it be fixed?
Like just like we want to make advances in medicine to detect cancer cells
before they metastasize.
Can we find human beings before they metastasize into,
into that final thing?
It's not an either or.
I think sometimes yes,
sometimes no.
I think sometimes it's probably a medical issue.
And what about research in terms of being able to find it,
find that the genetic markers that predispose you to that.
And there's a lot of times we have to wash these but isn't culture ultimately
led technology that does,
that is your culture.
Like when we call TV,
we call it program.
It programs you,
it teaches you about right and wrong and what's legal and what's not legal.
And if you're part of the pop culture,
you know,
you're programmed into it kind of mainstream consensus trance that basically
says we're moderately free.
As long as you don't physically hurt me and I don't physically hurt you.
And you know you don't do certain things,
but we know we have these kinds of frameworks to impose some kind of an order so
that the system can,
some kind of can have some kind of function.
So it just makes you wonder,
you know,
like especially with the privacy things,
are they really like spying on me or is it more like I'm a billion lines of code
mixed with a billion other lines of code.
It just a bunch of algorithms.
Here's what's coming,
here's what's,
and then they just detect when there's like weird behavior associated with
violence that they would zoom in,
they will use it,
they will use anything you've done wrong as an excuse to go and really go after
you,
you know,
briefly already want to fuck with you.
They can look at your stuff.
It's like,
oh he owns two larger lobster,
which is a federal offense.
All right,
let me ask you whether or not you bought,
he broken along.
When there's people that want to blow themselves up in subways,
don't you think that that's going to occupy most of them?
This is why,
because some guy who works there,
you fucked his ex girlfriend.
Oh snap.
Sorry.
Damn Shit just got real.
You know what I mean?
And then you're giving that guy the power to abuse it and that's what I don't
like and I think that's what this guy is saying is absolutely possible.
Here's my question that the people that work at the organization like him turn
to him as a high school dropout,
which is hilarious.
Like um,
he was,
your coder didn't use your guy.
Are you pretending you don't know this guy?
He's at play.
When is it ever worked?
This is the question we have to ask.
You know what that I saying,
if we don't understand history,
we're doomed or repeat it.
Let's look in the past.
What it,
what point has a government gain full access to the information flow of its
citizenry where it hasn't gone wrong?
Show me where,
what's what nation has it been where it's like,
Oh yes.
That was the,
that was that one government that knew,
that studied all the correspondence polish citizens and it didn't go wrong at
all.
It didn't tightened down.
It didn't become a security state.
It was a utopia.
No,
no,
no.
It doesn't exist.
It's no always bath.
Korea.
Yes.
But here's,
here's the counter argument to that.
Do you think that if given the proper instruments,
the citizenry could police themselves,
could we have nowadays that becomes like airbnb where everybody can rent their
own place and everybody else judges everybody else and you don't raise everybody
out to tell you about a good dentist.
You can just look online and you're connected to all the citizens hold you by
four and a half stars.
I was asking my brother,
I was like,
how do you know somebody from airbnb is not going to be some serial killer?
He's going to come into pieces.
He's like,
well cause you can look at the 50 other people that stayed at his house and they
rate his cleanness and the rain is you can go anywhere in the world and have
this joker's work now and Arrow succumb to regulate each other.
Self regulating networks.
So it's almost like we are connected to each other and it's like a homeo status
as being formed where the system is self regulators,
government in a time where we didn't have that ability.
Right now we do.
So the government,
right,
so it's governments and append to,
it's not utopia,
but these decentralized peer networks that self regulate each other with no top
down management but just lateral is leaning towards a kind of like space in
which we can,
we have congress because we didn't have the ability to send someone that
ourselves.
It's a from California,
we can't,
we can't speak in Washington,
so we need to send some guy as our congressman to speak for us,
but now we can speak for ourselves.
We don't need a lot of people.
Democracy 2.0 we need literally like Ios doesn't get an upgrade for our iPhone
every six months.
We freak out like we need to upgrade it.
Literally the way the whole governmental system works to use these rooms like it
should be online.
It's really simple.
The idea that anybody controls it is ridiculous.
It should be online and there should be some sort of anonymous type group that
controls the code,
makes sure that nobody can fuck with it,
like pick and was on top of Shit.
Maybe the AI global ethic amongst the anonymous is us by the way.
He was like,
no one's giving you,
here's the thing,
but no one's giving this power up.
This is where I think that that is where I think this fervent form of a naive
futurist comes into being aware and not just futurist spiritualist.
And a lot of other people think,
oh,
you know,
these,
uh,
as you're saying these,
what do you call it?
Peerless networks,
these decentralized peer.
Now and by the way,
when I say you,
I mean me too.
Cause I do have this hope that somehow this thing is just like an escalation
towards bliss and it's all to work itself out.
And I do think that,
but again,
if you look back at history,
you will see that even if a thing is become archaic and antiquated,
it doesn't mean that the people running that finger going to give it up.
No,
no,
they don't want to give it.
The only way they give it up is through violence.
And this,
that's our inevitability here for revolution here in our lifetime.
Kurzweil Kurzweil says,
Kurzweil says that that's actually not the case.
And he says that,
you know,
like the radio industry didn't want like TV to become a thing and it didn't,
it didn't need,
it didn't need to be violence for TV to like become more,
not talking about,
they didn't need to be goddamn revolution.
I'm ready to cheer it on Mama Howard,
but I'm ready to say here's some water.
You guys go out there and fight for us.
But I think that these technologies will meet resistance from the establishment,
but I don't think that it requires violence for transformation to occur.
I mean,
we're seeing it through social media.
I'm in the old,
what are you talking about?
Area Libera lip,
Liberia.
Uh,
the other one off.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Always gets,
always gets overthrown by,
aren't they?
Don't give up.
They don't give up and they have the guns.
So the only way to get him to give it up,
they can look the other way.
Which other ways?
When is it work?
People who are growing up with the dye outside different.
Understand what you're,
I don't,
I don't think that a representative governments impossible.
I just think that we have to have more accountability.
And the thing that gives more accountability than anything is the Internet.
It forces accountability.
So I think that's,
I think ultimately you can't record some pay anymore though.
You can.
Yes you can.
They can arrest you.
No,
they can't.
No.
I mean individual places have passed laws trying to make that real.
But there's a bunch of videos online that show people telling cops.
They told me today I couldn't take a picture of a Tsa.
I saw a baby being left on the counter.
So it was funny.
So I took a picture.
Sorry,
you can't take a picture of the check one mic that's raw.
What you're telling me is not true.
I'm going to take more pictures.
I got to say I don't,
I don't want there to be violence,
man.
I know that there needs to be,
I think the dream then naive dream of,
uh,
the futurists is,
it's like you look in the animal kingdom,
you look in and not just the animal kingdom,
but you look at any massive change that has ever happened is always surrounded
by a release of energy.
When things rapidly change,
there's a release of energy and energy releases are always violent.
Bam,
they're called explosion.
So it's like
B though,
just because I don't want it to be a psychic.
I can be a consciousness explosion and it doesn't,
it doesn't require Hiroshimas experiencing
that.
It's just,
again,
right.
The psychedelic state of,
you know,
seeing the whole history unfold in a matter of a few seconds.
This,
I think this is just,
it's slow.
So we're not really understanding what's happening,
but we're seeing all these psychedelics and coming back,
we're seeing all these things.
We're seeing all these paradigms crumble in front of our son,
and the reason being is because they're being espoused,
they're being exposed
to by the Internet.
It's just happening to us too slowly or it's happening.
It's too confusing as to which direction it's going to go.
There's too much peril in it.
It seems last two people that aren't just our luck.
Hey,
it's chasing like,
no,
no.
I don't want to need tola understand that it's not good to put women in
beekeeper outfits.
You know?
I completely concur with that,
but I had an interesting experience.
I was just in,
in,
in Berlin for a couple of days and I was hanging out with this.
I went to this like steam room and spa over at the Soho House there.
Yes.
And it's coed.
So beautiful naked girls are walking around and showering in front of you in
Germany and it's perfectly normal.
And of course I'm loving it,
but I'm also slightly like what's happening here?
And then I think we're just as primitive here with separating the men's room
into female room compared to them.
We're like the beekeeper suit.
Do you know what I mean?
Indeed.
I know you're saying,
I would think of myself as,
no,
we're liberal here in America and inept,
but look how shamelessly those woman are just walking around naked and it's like
relaxed.
We're not fucking,
I totally agree.
I totally agree with you.
I think that it's a,
it's your,
what you're seeing is a spectrum of,
of,
of men kind of controlling women.
Like if,
if a woman takes her shirt off at the beach,
she gets arrested in the United States.
Crazy.
But I think that if I'm going to be on some part of that spectrum,
I definitely want to be on the part of the spectrum where there's definite
definition of shirt is like a shoe lace or something.
I'd rather be no shoe lace at all.
But in that way,
all I'm saying is I don't understand the solution to,
um,
fundamentalists of any religion controlling massive populations.
Or in the case of North Korea,
uh,
people controlling master.
I don't see how some android,
Jesus,
I don't see how as wells manifestation of full brain emulation and the
subsequent empathic connection that happens with people.
I don't understand how that makes a person who's wheel the control over a chunk
of land using a false god.
Uh,
I don't understand how that's going to make them be like,
you know what,
I guess I was wrong.
Well,
you can all just,
but our,
our society has been transformed by a change in consciousness.
I mean,
you could argue that the 60s fundamentally changed the way we think.
I mean this place used to be a lot more puritan than it is now drawn.
Used to be a lot more liberal.
Okay,
so you have it,
you have both things happening,
what cycles?
You have things to be wrong.
It's very liberal now of the,
amongst the people.
Yeah.
The [inaudible] a very secular is,
but the govern the government is what's really got an office,
but there's always going to be the ayatollah that's the supreme leader.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's really a weird situation.
So strange.
And the guy who was the I had told has been the,
I told us it's like 89 or something like that.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean,
something crazy like that.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what,
man,
let me just say this cause I don't want to come off sounding like Ari.
Like I want some violent,
right.
I don't want why I see it a habitable.
Did you ever have Steven pinker on the show?
So Steven pinker called the better angels of our nature.
He wrote a book called the better angels of our nature is a tech.co Ted talk
called the myth of violence.
And he actually went up there and explained that the chances of a man die at the
hands of another man today are the lowest than they've ever been in a lot of all
of human history.
The world has actually never been less violent than it is today.
100,000 people like,
and it's a lot.
But I,
I guess what he's saying is that it used to be worried.
I mean,
the Mongols killed a million and a day.
Right,
right,
right.
I see what you're saying.
Yes.
Is that right?
It's that spectrum.
It's a spectrum day.
Yeah.
Some insane number.
It was probably like,
I might be exaggerating,
there would be 72 hours to 72 hours.
It killed a million people with horses on horseback.
No nuclear bomb to swords that say,
must be so tired after that.
That's when he got to run.
When they're that tired.
Oh,
actually really killed a million people.
Yeah.
Lillian.
That's a,
we have to really sort of grasped,
it's hard to,
but we have to try to grasp just what a short period of time we haven't been
barbarians.
Yeah.
I mean,
even the Catholic church even,
you,
you go back to the 15 hundreds,
they were drinking.
They had like mistresses.
The pope's had mistresses.
They even raised kids had armies.
Yeah.
They rape kids.
They had armies.
They had four armies.
The Pope had army.
Did.
Karthik Catholic Church had armies.
The Vatican and an army behind it.
It's crazy.
I mean that you're talking about like really nutty shit.
Like they asked for,
uh,
the,
the pope's help once in fighting off.
The Mongols were here late.
Yeah.
I didn't want to send some to the troops.
They got lucky.
Fucking muggles died off.
Ooh,
can I,
here's the thing,
man.
I want to be pessimistic again because I've been to,
I keep thinking about this,
so it's like,
okay,
okay.
In the same way that it used to be,
if a person had a great idea and wanted to transmit it,
you'd have to get a printing press and he'd have to like,
you know,
to get the idea around,
it took a long time.
It would have to go buy boats,
right.
So now it's like if you want to build a like a nuclear bomb,
like it's really hard.
Like you've got to have centrifuges plutonium.
It's a fucking bitch.
Like you can't just do it if you want to build a nuke.
But as matter is,
is it three d printers began to become more and more advanced and they start
working at the atomic level.
Then in the same way that we have accessibility to instantaneous communication,
people are going to have accessibility to instantaneous print guns,
creation of,
of all kinds of fucked up weapons.
The need
and account of all the people in our community that we're going to need an
account of them in a loving way.
Our society like looking out for each other.
The idea is that every one guy's basement with a nuclear bomb.
You're right,
you're right.
But the idea is that every baby has a potential to become an awesome human
being.
Right?
That's the idea.
But that some of them just get shit rolls of the dice and they get one windup
when two asshole meth head parents who fucking leave them in a basement one day
for 24 hours and they starve to death.
You know,
this shit like that happens to kids.
You just get a shit roll of the dice or you can get an awesome roll the dice,
you know?
I mean that's possible too.
It's,
I think it's our job collectively as,
as a human species to concentrate on the least fortunate amongst us.
I think it's,
it's the,
the thing that everyone takes for granted,
everyone ignores and every single guy who runs for president doesn't bring it
up.
They know.
They never say,
look,
our society is only as strong as its weakest link.
Right.
We got a bunch of people that are being ignored and they,
they're an awesome resource.
If we,
if we educated them and help them and move them forward in some way,
who knows what kind of great benefit you could get out of this.
Alright.
Unity.
It's true.
I just think of that guy on locked up raw that one or like,
you know like the guy,
I can't remember which guide is like one of these like the people that you see
on locked up raw or just like,
you know like I think,
cause you know I've,
I've thought,
oh I know the way to fix that.
It's like you flood the prisons with Lsd and like give these people help a
little.
That would definitely help a little.
You're eventually going to have a 12 monkeys situation.
I think do you can do a site is going to have much effect on the rest of the
population with like a toxin or like a bunch of nuclear weapons that it'll just
drastically change everything.
I think society has always thought that this was coming or not.
You know,
it's like there's always people that believe that the apocalypse is around the
corner and there's all these people that had faith and like
Jason said,
it's,
this is the safest time to be alive ever.
But yet we're still like fuck the sky's falling.
But you know,
almost like a part of being a human to recognize all the flaws around us to make
it glaringly obvious that we're aware of them and to focus more attention on it.
Hold on.
Really slowed down the progress.
US,
US being scared and neurotic and almost like negative has been biologically
selected for to warn us against potential consequences.
Like the,
you know,
the early,
the early cavemen who was chilling out and looking at the sky got eaten quickly.
The one that was like scared of impending doom survive.
So there's no coincidence that we have evolved that,
but until we start like playing with our own genomes,
like we can't change our basic dispositions,
which is a pay attention to whatever we think is dangerous.
But I think it does have,
you know,
knowledge is power when you appreciate,
Oh really?
The world has never been safer.
That's interesting.
Not to say there's not a thought of the things to worry about.
It's not to say that there's not school shootings and three d printing guns
could be dangerous,
but let's look at the actual facts as it is today.
Yeah.
But all it would take,
but in the beginning,
if one guy out of a hundred of them went a little nuts,
who punched some people,
right?
Then as technology got better,
he'd stabbed two people and then I stopped.
And then as technology got better,
he put off a bomb and then as technology got better,
he flew a plane into a building.
And as technology gets better,
you can effect millions and millions of millions of people all at once with just
one.
Just one guy that falls in the cracks.
Well this is very,
very
much like the Internet,
but it's funny.
All right,
what you're saying goes against your hate of the surveillance state because you
could see how when an accelerating
technology where people can blow each other up with increasing,
uh,
within a increasing competency,
you can see the necessity for perhaps a,
you know,
an observation of her.
It's a fuck.
That's what I'm saying.
It's a pickle,
man.
That's going to happen anyway.
You're never going to stay fully.
You can't monitor everything something's going to happen.
Doesn't mean you don't try to stop it.
I mean,
the trend seems they're reversible.
The trend towards,
uh,
everybody having access to everything at all times.
I think we're going to have a real problem with money because money right now is
just,
you know,
used to be based on gold and now we've got this one's and zero's thing that
we're rocking.
That doesn't really make any sense at all.
I think that bitcoin in the last thing that comes right after bitcoin is going
to be the one,
oh,
if you guys heard about this shit,
I wonder,
I mean,
I think it's,
it's,
it's we,
we live in a really strange time because as access to information gets more and
more transparent and more and more free,
where we all have access to everything.
Well then what is that?
What exactly is financial resources?
Yeah.
Where are those ones and Zeros?
Where do they go if nothing gets,
sorry,
go ahead.
I'm just saying it's like there'll be a permeation point where transparency,
it gets to a point where everyone has access to everything at all times.
You're not going to be able to store any secrets,
so you're not going to mail to have money.
You're not going to be able to put ones and Zeros all in your bank account.
Does it mean anything?
So we will take your ones and Zeros.
There also might not be a reason for anybody to hurt each other.
Like,
you know,
it might not have to be that when the Kenneth says we're all going to move into
universes of our own construction,
but then like Kurzweil and Peter Diamandis just say,
you know,
technology is a resource liberating mechanism.
The whole idea of scarcity is just contextual.
You know,
we fight over 1% of the freshwater in the world when this is a water planet.
Desalinization revolution could give us all the water we could ever need.
We fight over energy.
We get 10,000 times more energy from the sun than we would ever need.
With nanotechnology.
Matter becomes a programmable medium.
We can turn anything into anything.
So I mean,
when we have just like infinite abundance,
potentially,
what would we fight about?
There will be no incentive
sensitive to fight pussy go.
What did we could call Chloe?
I live in virtual reality.
Diamonds.
Girls don't want to fake diamonds.
They want real diamonds that came from coal and the guys are going to want real
pussy that you earn.
Oh,
she's a real person and have,
do they have virtual games where we can be the heroes in our own unit?
In your argument and that terrifying flaw in your argument is the assumption
that people do things for a reason.
You're saying people do things because they don't have enough or they do things
because of this or that.
Some of the most horrible things are done for no reason at all.
They're done because the bio computer that,
that somebody is running clicked the wrong way and they decided it'd be fun to
hear the sound of a teenage boy that's snap like a clown.
That's a cancer cell.
That's a,
that's a thing that's not doing,
it's not moving towards complexity and organization and the sublime.
Right?
Like the rest of the evolutionary process.
Why there's the urge to kill it.
Right.
There's the urgency kill it.
But the interesting thing,
and I think this,
I heard,
I think Mckenna said this,
there's this relay,
there's a race happening right now.
There's a race happening.
Cause it's,
it's not as though these two things can exist.
At the same time.
It's like we were talking about this and I've been thinking about a bunch of
sense.
How you know in phones of course the are their conflict minerals.
What's the name of that shit?
And Fuck,
what's it called?
Hold on.
Phones is cold hands.
So we know that in our phones,
in this,
uh,
device,
it's allowing us this greater connectivity is the suffering of children and
African an African minds.
So we see in nature that there is this intertwining of horror and of darkness
and light very,
and to think that somehow technology is going to make things all light is to say
that we will actually rewire the universe when in fact it seems like what's
happening is an acceleration on both sides of the scale.
And is that acceleration happens.
There'll be an equivalent amount of this orgasmic Utopian Tayley our day.
Shar don't Omega Point with the other side of the thing,
which is well,
the absolute obliteration of all humanity through nuclear weapons or bioweapons.
Now here's the hopeful thing is what a Martin Luther King said,
which is the universe bends in the direction of justice.
And there is this hope that there's a refraction.
Is this the same where things are going towards the direction of creation
instead of,
yeah,
with Steven Johnson says it's not utopia,
but it's leaning that way.
So you know you could do the things are better.
They're not perfect,
they're better.
Technology amplifies the good in us.
That amplifies the bat at us in a,
in us,
but maybe it amplifies the good a little bit more than it amplifies the bad so
that eventually it might subvert completely.
The light might swallow the darkness.
That's the trippy might transcend,
enter,
be completely,
you know,
we might become immortal gods living outside of time,
you know?
And maybe that's the singularity.
Yeah,
may sounds a lot like a battle between Hell and heaven.
It does,
doesn't,
it almost seems like that's happened before.
It's not a coincidence.
We need those archetypes to make sense of what's happening.
We've used the same archetypes,
religion,
salvation,
transcendence,
the same things.
The difference is that religion never produced with technology produced
religion.
Never let us fly through the air.
Religion never give us cell phones and never gave us the Internet.
Technology does.
So in the whole and the thing hole heard in our desire to to to,
to believe that these things are going to help us transcend our limitations.
You know the technology is actually delivering a little bit more than the
previous stuff.
Oh a lot,
right?
Dairy with your a little bit.
Well there you go.
A lot.
Cyborg arms and trying to make friends and the relatives are hearing again.
They may Galileo,
apologize
church.
Yeah,
there was,
what did you have to do with you guys want to see a trippy video but us being
cyborg.
So we're gonna wrap this up with this tribute video.
Cool to get out of here.
I'm working all day.
Let's do it fast to everyone who's participated.
Shroom fest pitches.
God is love,
everything's going to be fine.
Forget all that explosion shit.
And before we go,
we would just like to thank hover.com go to hover com forward
Rogan,
get 10% off of your domain name purchases and stamps.com if you click on the
microphone entering the Code Word J R H,
get yourself a special offer and on it.com that's o,
n n I t,
use the code name,
Rogan,
save yourself 10% of any and all supplements.
I've had a wacky few,
uh,
actually like month and a half lately,
ladies and gentlemen.
And uh,
I,
I wouldn't have been able to do all this stuff if I didn't enjoy the shit out of
it.
And it's a fascinating experience.
So I want to,
I want to thank all of you.
Uh,
and uh,
I want you guys to,
uh,
follow all my friends on Twitter,
including Jason Silva.
What is it?
Is Jason Silva at Jason Silva at Ari?
Should fear watch my story teller show online on Youtube?
Yeah.
Is it was a couple of them now because the first one was really good too.
Where are you?
Where'd you feel knows?
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah,
that's what it looked like.
It looked like some sort of a strip club.
It's tied to the environment is perfect.
And uh,
Tj Miller is one was really good too.
That was a,
that was really funny and it's,
it's,
it's a really interesting sort of set up the way you have it.
And I love that comedy central had the balls to put that on line like that,
just produce it and make it like a real show,
like a legit TV show.
Put it online and,
and if it gets a good reaction they'll probably wind up doing something like
that on television.
All the comics,
all the comments like you do what you feel is bright.
Yeah.
So go and check it out and support it.
Joey Diaz is coming and support it folks.
Cause uh,
Arsha fear is a bad motherfucker concept of sound and pass it around and he
would like to get some of that sweet,
sweet TV money.
I really,
it's lot to put on a good show for people.
You do.
I want to,
your intentions are a hundred percent pure.
You're a real legit comic.
Ours fear.
It's a an honor watching you grow from being a dude who was just sort of getting
on stage the first time to be in a legit headliner.
It's awesome.
It's cool to say.
Wow.
Same to you'd Duncan Trussell use sexy.
This is not happening.
Alright,
you fucks,
uh,
file Duncan Trussell on Twitter at Dunkin d u n c a n Trestle t r U.
S.
E.
L.
This is my podcast,
Duncan Trussell family hour s double l.
That's Duncan Trussell.
Awesome.
All right.
If I may add I just a,
I would love everyone to check in.
Check out brain games on national geographic.
Yes.
I have a new series that airs Monday night at nine.
We're doing season two now that felon,
but currently we're still airing it.
Next Monday is the final episode,
actually the 12th episode.
So please check out brain games on national geographic.
And I also launched a new youtube channel called youtube.com/shots of awe where
I'm releasing new videos of my craziest Breslow's psychedelic videos every week.
So youtube.com/shots of off and subscribe to shots of awe.
Just Awu.
I don't would just have kittens all day long.
This one is shots of awe,
awe,
but if you check it out,
that new videos called we are already cyborgs.
That's the one I want you to,
to check it out
perfectly with that.
Jason Silva,
let's do you have that thing up.
youtube.com/shots of vodka.
It's the first one down.
It's called,
we are already cyborgs.
Oh,
there you are already cyborgs.
We can't get to God the Ibw to Veda play.
You're fired.
Destroy the planet.
How dare you.
All right,
well let's just recommend that people want,
it's called,
uh,
it's shots of all on youtube and we are already cyborgs,
which I concur sir.
Awesome.
I concur.
You're a bad motherfucker.
Cosmic Dick slinger.
Oh yeah.
That's a great Jason Silva for that.
Thank you for having [inaudible] fear powerful.
Duncan Trussell powerful.
Jamie,
we're out of here.
You're dirty fox.
We'll see you next week with new Shenanigans and Ari Shaffir and I go to Alaska
to conquer the great white north.
Yeah,
go fishing like a motherfucker right here,
dog.
All right,
you're fox.
Awesome.
See you soon.
We love the shit out of Ya.
All right.
Big Kiss.